Rồi các bạn ơi à buổi lần trước chúng ta
buổi chủ nhật chúng ta học được có một
tiếng nhở học được có một tiếng hôm nọ
chúng ta đang dừng lại ở cái đoạn chúng
ta chúng ta huấn luyện một cái chúng ta
huấn luyện cái mô hình dành cho bài toán
time series forecasting đúng không đá
qua lại một tí nhá cũng cũng cũng không
có gì phức tạp cả đúng không đầu tiên
chúng ta đọc dữ liệu vào đúng không cái
bộ rượu chúng ta là cái bộ CO2 như thế
này bộ CO2 như thế này đúng không này
các bạn chờ đến Ừ. Bộ diện như thế này
nó có những cái ô nó bị khuyết đúng
không? Thì đầu tiên chúng ta chúng ta
chúng ta
chúng ta đọc cái bộ rượu vào đúng không?
Chúng ta chúng ta thực hiện nội suy cho
cái cột CO2. Vì sao chúng ta lại vì sao
chúng ta lại nội suy mà chúng ta không
xóa bé chúng đi? Tại vì là dữ liệu dạng
time suy nó có cái tính liên tục. Nó có
cái tính liên tục. Thì nếu mà chúng ta
chúng ta xóa nó đi như vậy rồi thì sau
này khi chúng ta dùng rượu chúng ta hối
lượng mô hình nó sẽ không còn cái tính
liên tục, nó không còn cái sự continuous
nữa thì nó sẽ chúng ta sẽ không sử dụng
được để chúng ta huấn luyện mô hình đúng
không? Nhưng mà phải có thể chúng ta
điền chúng vào chúng ta dùng nội suy.
Đấy sau chúng ta trực văn hóa dữ liệu
đúng không? Trực văn hóa dữ liệu.
Thế sau đó chúng ta convert dữ liệu
chúng ta từ cái dạng gốc ban đầu thành
cái dạng mà chúng ta có thể đưa vào
trong mô hình. Đây chạy lại nhá. Chạy
lại một tí nhá. trên này nhá.
Ừ
chẽ lại một tí nhá.
À
chết copy thiếu copy thiếu nó tích trên
này cơ.
Đây copy từ đầu đúng không? Đến
đây chưa? Thì lại nhá.
Đây nhá. Đúng không? Sau cái dệ chúng ta
convert xong nó trông như thế này đúng
không? Nó trông như thế này. À chúng ta
có cái cột cột với cột CO2 là cái cột
gốc ban đầu. Chúng ta sẽ tạo ra cái cột
CO21,
CO22, CO23, CO24 và cái cột tag hit đúng
không? CO2 đến CO24 là những cái input
đầu vào trong cái target là cái chính là
cái quy định cái cái cái nhãn chúng ta
cần phải dự đoán đó đúng không? Đấy thì
đây là dự liệu của chúng ta xong chúng
ta tách ra thôi. Có time chúng ta cái
time chúng ta drop đi bỏ đi CO2 đến CO24
nó là và cái input đầu vào là X đấy đúng
không? Cái target là cái output đầu ra
là Y đấy đúng không? Đấy. Sau đó chúng
ta chúng ta tách dữ liệu tách chúng ta
cũng không dùng cái hàm chest split có
sẵn mà chúng ta chúng ta phải tách thủ
công đúng không? Tại vì sao? Tại vì
chúng ta tách là nó cũng cần phải có cái
tính liên tục đúng không? Không không để
tách kiểu ngẫu ngẫu nhiên random được.
Được chưa? Sa mình dùng mô hình hôm nọ
chúng ta có giải hết được lý do là vì
sao mà khi chúng ta chúng ta dùng mô
hình random fred kết quả lại tồi như vậy
tại vì là random for nó không có khả
năng dự đoán những cái giá trị nằm ngoài
cái khoảng nó đã từng nhìn thấy trong
quá trình huấn luyện. Trong quá trình
huấn luyện thì chúng ta đưa vào cái bộ
dữ liệu là cái đoạn mà từ năm 1958 đến
năm 199 mấy đấy. 1993 994 gì đấy đúng
không? Trong cái khoản này cái lợi CO2
nó nằm trong khoảng từ 31 mười mấy đến
gần 360.
Thì quá trình huấn luyện cái mô hình
chúng ta nó nhìn thấy dữ liệu trong
khoản này thì nó quá trình nó dự đoán ấ
nó cũng chỉ có khả năng nó dự đoán trong
cái khoảng này thôi. Nó không dự đoán
nhỏ hơn 31 mấy được. Nó không dự đoán
lớn hơn 360 được. Nó chỉ trong cái
khoảng này thôi đúng không? Thế nên là
do đó khi chúng ta đem mô hình đi triển
khai trong thế thì nó cũng chỉ có khả
năng dự án trong khoảng này nó không có
lệch ra ngoài được đúng không? Đấy.
Thế còn nhữ khi mà chúng ta dùng mô hình
linear reaction thì lại không có vấn đề
gì đúng không? linearation nó hoàn toàn
nó có thể dự đoán vượt ra khỏi cái
khoảng trong cái phạm vi mà nó từng được
nhìn thấy trong quá trình huấn luyện nên
thì
đúng không chạy bị bình thường đây thân
thể hoàn toàn bình thường đúng không
chúng ta có một vài những cái magic như
là à đúng không chúng ta có đây phần
quân hóa đúng không cái thì mô hình nó
mô hình nó các bạn thấy nó rất là tốt
đây các bạn mô hình nó rất là tốt. Đây
coefficient of determination 99% 0,99 nó
rất là tốt. Nên các bạn thấy là muốn
nhìn rõ cái select zoom nó lên này. Đây
đúng không? Bây giờ các bạn nhìn thấy nó
rõ hơn đúng không? Thế và chúng ta magic
thì đây được chưa? Đây là cái nội dung
chúng ta dừng buổi hôm nọ nó trực quần
hóa thì đây rồi chưa? Chúng chúng ta
phân tích xem là vì sao cái mô hình đơn
giản như mô hình linear reaction nó chạy
rất là tốt. Trong khi mô hình random
fres là mô hình advance rồi trong các
cái mô hình trong machining thì random
fr là một cái mô hình tương tương đối
nâng cao rồi sau này sao nó lại tồi như
vậy được chưa?
Thế thế nhưng mà hôm nọ chúng ta mới
dừng lại ở việc là chúng ta mới dự đoán
được một giá trị trong tương lai thôi
đúng không? Chúng ta mới dự đoán được
một giá trị trong tương lai thôi. Thế
nhưng mà về mặt bản chất chúng ta với
cách recursip recept time c forcasting
này chúng ta hoàn toàn chúng có thể dự
đoán được nhiều dữ tr trong trong tương
lai. Logic thì rất là đơn giản thôi đúng
không? Chúng ta cứ dự đoán được một cái
mới chúng ta lại kết nạp cái mới này vào
trong cái danh sách của input đầu vào
đúng không? Chúng ta cứ kết nạp thêm,
kết nạp thêm, kết nạp thêm như vậy thì
thì chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ c dựng cái
giá trị tiếp theo đúng không? Bây giờ
thử nhá. Thử thử thử thử thử làm thử
demo nhá. Đúng không? Thay vì thay vì
tôi chỉ dự đoán một giá trị trong tương
lai thôi, tôi sẽ dự đoán nhiều giá trị
hơn thì ta làm nào? Đầu tiên là tôi phải
comment chỗ này đi, đúng không? Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ fit xong rồi đúng không? Bây
giạy cái đoạn predit này nữa. Được chưa?
Tôi fit xong là mấy bạn ờ ôi cứ chạy
cũng được, chạy cũng được, không có vấn
đề gì cả. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ tôi
chạy xong nó có cái performance rồi nhá.
Tôi sẽ bắt đầu tôi tạo ra một cái ví dụ
là
mình gọi nó là gì gọi là
input data đi đúng không? Input data đi
đúng không? Thì bây giờ input data chúng
ta sẽ tạo ra đầu tiên chúng sẽ sẽ sẽ
ngồi bịa ra thôi đúng không? Bịa ra
thôi. Ví dụ là các bạn thấy là bây giờ
cái mô hình của mình là cái mô hình dựa
vào năm giá trị liên tiếp để dựa cái giá
trị thứ sáu đúng không? Thế bây giờ mình
sẽ phải ngồi bịa thì mình cũng phải ngồi
biệa ra năm ông liên tiếp thôi. Ví dụ
thế là mình bịa ra chỗ ví dụ là ba lấy
gốc từ 340 nhá. Được chưa? Ví dụ đây
nhá. 340,5
340,8 đúng không? 341,2
đấy. Mình cứ ngồi bịa thôi đúng không?
Ngồi bịa thôi để xem xem làm như nào. 3
4 1 phẩy 6 đúng không? A 41,9. Ví dụ như
vậy được chưa? Ví dụ như vậy được chưa?
Thì bây giem nó cho qua mô hình qua mình
mình dự đoán đúng không? Đây xem cái
đoạn này này được chưa?
Model predict này x test này đúng không?
Mình đ xest input data. Nhưng có một cái
điểm chú ý là gì? Là cái input data này
nó là nó là mảng mấy chiều các bạn nhỉ?
Input data này nó là mảng mấy chiều các
bạn? Cái input data nó phải là mảng mấy
chiều?
Cái chỗ này này, cái chỗ mà đem vào này,
cái chỗ mà các bạn nhét vào trong này nó
phải là mảng mấy chiều các bạn?
Bảng máy chiều
mình mới chạy liệu nó có lỗi không?
Cái input mình đưa vào đây nó phải là
bằng mấy chiều?
Cái input mình phải đưa đây bằng mấy
chiều?
Thì dựa trên x test này là dựa trên x
test là mảng mấy chiều đúng không? Ở
trên các bạn đưa cái x test vào được rồi
đúng không? Các bạn đưa xest vào được
rồi thì có nghĩa là x test là mảng mấy
chiều thì đây cũng phải là mảng tường
đây chiều đúng không? Nó phải là mảng
hai chiều đúng không? X test ở trên nó
là mảng hai chiều mà đúng không? Hôm nọ
mình hỏi các bạn câu y hệt rồi. Hôm nọ
mình hỏi một câu y chang đúng không? Thì
input đồ hà nó phải là mảng hai chiều
đúng không? Số hàng đại diện cho số
lượng sample các bạn đưa vào còn số cột
là đại diện cho số lượng feature. Tất
nhiên là trong quá trình mình test thì
mình có nhiều sample còn quá trình mình
triển khai nó chỉ có một sample thôi
đúng không? Nhưng mà bản chất nó phải là
mảng hai chiều đúng không? Đưa mảng một
chiều nó sẽ lỗi ngay. Đây này. Mảng một
chiều đây nhá. Các bạn nhìn đưa mảng một
chiều vào này. Đúng không? Đây thả chạy
cũng biết lỗi đế này chưa? Kảng một
chiều không không được đúng không? Hai
chiều đóng cái ngoặc ngoài nữa này.
Đây được chưa? Đấy mình in ra nhá. Pr in
này được chưa? Predict nhá. Được chưa?
In này nhá.
Này các bạn nhìn này. Đây chưa? Đây là
cái dự đoán này.
Đây đúng không các bạn? Thấy dự đoán
mình đây đúng không? Dự đoán đây này. 34
bao nhiêu này đúng không? Tất nhiên là
mình muốn lấy ra cái giá trị góc bên
trong thì mình lấy tử số 0 này. Tại vì
là mình chỉ mua sample thôi mà. Đúng
mình chỉ mua sample thôi thì nó như này
được chưa?
IC đây đúng không? Về mặt bản mặt chất
xem nó là cái gì nhá đúng không? À cái
gì nhỉ?
T này
nó là 5 array đúng không? Nó là 5 array.
Được chưa?
Mình có thể convert nó thành dạng list
bình thường trước. Ví dụ các bạn nhìn
nhá.
số tại vì nó là đây về mặt bản chất nó
là cái giá trị này này cái giá trị Ibrix
này này mặt bản chất nó là một cái à một
cái array không chiều nó không phải một
chiều nó trên một số thì nó là nó là
không chiều số chiều nó là bằng 0 số
chiều là bằng 0 nhìn nó là số như vậy
thôi mà nó không phải là số bình thường
nó là 5π array được chưa muốn biến anh
nó thành số bình thường thì à thì các
bạn có thể ví dụ là trước khi các bạn
đưa về là với phần tử 0 các bạn cho nó
thành một cái list trước chấm to list
này. Được chưa?
List này.
Đấy. Bây giờ nó thành số float này. Nó
thành float này. Được chưa? Số bình
thường này. Được chưa? Tại vì nh các bạn
nhìn nhá. Mình làm từng bước một nhá.
Bình thường này.
Bình thường nhá. Bình thường ấy cái
prick này này. Thôi mình mình tắt mấy
cái trên này nhá. Cái trên này nhìn
vướng quá. Tắt nó đi các bạn nhìn nhá.
Bình thường thế này
bình thường nhá. Cái output của mô hình
này, cái output cái IPX này ấ nó là một
cái number array. Đây là một cái mảng
một chiều được chưa? Mảng một chiều các
bạn mà lấy ra cái nhân của nó, lấy ra
cái phần tử này đúng không? Nó chỉ có
một chiều và một phần tử thôi thì nó vẫn
là 5 paray. Nhưng đây sẽ là 5 paray
không chiều được chưa? Số chiều nó là 0.
Cái này người ta gọi là scala đấy. Scala
value đấy đúng không? Scala này. Scala
được chưa? Scala. Scala nghĩa là không
chiều. Vector thì là
array hoặc là vector thì là một chiều,
matric thì là hai chiều được chưa? Scala
thì là không chiều không chiều t nó chu
đúng một giá trị thôi. Được chưa? Đấy.
Bây giờ đây đúng không? Trước khi mình
đây mình lấy phần tử 0 trước đấy mình
biến nó thành trước đấy mình thấy mình
lấy nó thành list bình thường thì mình
trong n có một cái hàm là to list. Đấy
thì trước đó thì nó là array to list thì
nó đ thành list thôi.
List này được chưa? Lấy phần tử số 0
này. Được chưa?
Đấy flot này. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ có
nó rồi xong mình sẽ gắn đúng không? Bây
giờ các bạn muốn nó dự án được nhiều giá
trị thì các bạn phải làm một cái vòng
lặp đúng không? Độ for
in của 10 chẳng hạn đúng không? 10 đúng
không? Đầu tiên là ebak nhá. Đúng chưa?
Eriak này đúng không? Sau đó chúng ta
phải
in ra đúng không? Mình sẽ in ra từ bây
giờ mình sẽ in ra input trước đi. Mình
sẽ in ra là print
à input data nhá.
Mình print
như này nhá. Sau đó thì mình sẽ làm gì?
Sau đó mình sẽ mình sẽ phải update cái
input này. Update bằng cái nào mình sẽ
bỏ cái ống xa nhất đi. Đúng không? 1 này
cộng với cái gì nhở? Cộng với
này cộng với cái yx này
thật ra là cũng chả cái 0 này cứ in
thẳng ra đúng không? Đây cộng với
I thôi
đúng không?
Input data như này đúng không? Bản thân
nó là một cái list rồi đúng không? Các
bạn muốn nối hai cái list với nhau các
bạn dùng toán tưởng cộng là xong. Đây
nhá. Ví dụ này bạn muốn cộng hai cái
list với nhau cũng không có không có cái
script nào đây đúng không? Mình có cái
list a bằng đúng không? 1 2 3 4 ví dụ
như vậy đi đúng không? Bằng 5 này đúng
không các bạn? A bằng a cộng b này green
a đúng không? Đây mình ghép hai cái list
với nhau như này được chưa? Nó đóng tử
cộng thôi đúng không? Thì muốn cộng như
vậy thì cái ông B nó nó cũng phải là
list mới cộng được. Thế nên là ở đây
mình để nó nguyên nó là list này mình
cộng vào được chưa? Đấy. Y lên đúng
không? Cái này các bạn chả cần dùng y
đúng đấ gạch là xong. Được chưa? Nhạy
thử nhá.
Đấy. Đẹp chưa? Đây đúng không? 340 này
đúng không? Output đây. Xong mình bỏ cái
ông xa nhất đi. Cho cái ông này vào
chưa? Ghép cái ông mới này vào này. Được
chưa? Thôi
đấy.
Đây là cái mô hình của mình chưa?
mình đem mình mình dự đoán được nhiều
giá trị trong tương lai. Tất nhiên là
giá trị càng xa trong tương lai mà chúng
ta muốn dự đoán thì nó sẽ làm sao hả các
bạn? Giá trị mà nó càng xa trong tương
lai thì nó sẽ càng làm sao?
Nó sẽ càng làm sao? Ừ nó càng sai lệch
đúng không các bạn? Giống như kiểu là dự
báo thời tiết cũng thế thôi đúng không?
Chúng ta chả cần tính toán đúng không?
Chúng ta chả tính toán chúng ta chúng ta
cũng thừa hiểu là gì? là giá trị mà nó
càng xa trong tương lai thì độ xác nó sẽ
càng thấp đúng không? Đây đây là điều
hiển nhiên đúng không? Các bạn dự đoán
ngay ngày mai kiểu gì nó chả dễ hơn. Các
bạn dự đoán trong một tuần tới đúng
không? Đây là điều hiển nhiên khỏi cần
phải chứng minh đúng không? Ai cũng hiểu
đúng không? Đấy thì đây là cách tiếp cận
đầu tiên đúng không? Cách tiếp cận chúng
ta làm việc trong cả buổi lần trước đúng
không? Cái tiện này thì gọi là thì gọi
là recursos multet time series for
casting. Được chưa? Thật ra thật ra ấy
đáng nhẽ ra ấy đáng nhẽ ra thì sau này
các bạn đi làm các bạn cũng không phải
ngồi các bạn không cần ngồi các bạn phải
phải phải phải phải phải bò ra các bạn
ngồi cốt xuống bước này đâu. Đây là các
bạn xong cái phần thực hành đầu tiên
nhá. Mình chỉ bạn một cái thư viện nó
thư viện nó nó là một cái spinoff từ se
nó cũng nó gọi là nó gọi là cái gì nhỉ?
Quên mất tên rồi nhỉ.
Say forcast đây rồi nhá. Thế viện này
các bạn nhìn cái logo của nó nhìn nó
giống giống size k không cũng cái màu
chủ đạo như này đúng không? Cũng cũng
màu chủ đạo như này được chưa? Cái này
dùng dùng này thì rất là dễ luôn. Cái
này các bạn các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái này
các bạn còn chẳng cần các bạn phải tự
load dữ liệu cơ các bạn. À ờ không phải
không phải không không cần load các bạn
sẽ không cần phải các bạn sẽ không cần
phải convert thủ công như này. Các bạn
sẽ không cần phải convert thủ công là
các bạn load dữ liệu vào rồi các bạn
phải ngồi tách tách tách ra. Các bạn
không cần làm như vậy. Các bạn nhìn này.
Dùng rất là dễ luôn. Các bạn cứ load dữ
liệu vào nó sẽ tự làm cho các bạn luôn.
Nã tự làm các bạn luôn. Dùng rất là dễ.
B có mấy dòng rất là dễ.
Đấy cái thư viện nó nhá. Do
documentation nhá. Cài thì rất là dễ
thô. Cài được một dòng xong pip cách
install xong luôn. Đây SK forcast các
bạn nhớ là hôm nọ chúng ta có cái in l
đúng không? Đấy nó có rất nhiều thư viện
nó xoay quanh sa rất nhiều thư viện. Đây
đúng không? Đây là thư viện để dư hiện
data balancing này. Được chưa? Đây là
thư viện dùng để
documentation user guide này rất nhiều
example này. Đấy các bạn nhìn này đây
này các bạn thấy có đúng hai bước chưa?
Các bạn nhìn thấy chưa? Đây này hai kiểu
đúng không? Direct multistep này
recursip đây chúng ta vừa xong recurship
rồi này. Recurip nhá đây các bạn nhìn
đây. Đây đây cái hình lấy từ đây mà ra
này.
Đấy đúng không? Sau các bạn đi làm các
bạn sẽ dùng cái này cho nó nhanh là các
bạn dùng kết quả cách làm thì nó tức là
nó đóng gói hết những cái thứ ở bên
trong rồi. Nó nó gói hết cái thứ ở ở bên
trong rồi nên các bạn không không nhìn
thấy thôi chứ thật ra nó cũng làm như
thế này. Đây cũng lo rượu vào này. Được
chưa? Các bạn có cái bộ rượu này được
chưa? Các bạn sẽ không cần phải ngồi các
bạn ngồi các bạn ghép rượu thủ công các
bạn lại shift từng ô từng ô xong các bạn
stack vào với nhau các bạn không cần
phải làm như vậy nó làm hết cho các bạn.
Thế nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn chúng ta
dùng ngay này thì chúng ta sẽ nếu chúng
ta dùng ngay này thì chúng ta sẽ không
hiểu hiểm trong nó làm cái gì. Đấy nên
là mình tách cho các bạn thành từng cái
bước con. Được chưa?
Đấy cái này rất là chi tiết các bạn. Các
bạn đang dùng chỉ có mấy dòng thôi. Được
chưa?
Các bạn thử về hôm nay về các bạn thử
các bạn dùng cái các bạn dùng thư viện
này đi coi như không có mình hướng dẫn.
Thật ra việc các bạn thật ra việc các
bạn có cái tên rồi các bạn vứt lên trên
chat GPT hoặc là các bạn vứt lên close
nó hướng dẫn cho các bạn ngay đúng
không? Các bạn thử thử thử tự mình dùng
đi xem kết quả của nó v. Tất nhiên nó
vẫn có một cái sự khác biệt chút nhỏ
nhỏ. Ví dụ ở đây cái demo của người ta ấ
người ta dùng mô hình khác đúng không?
Mình dùng linear re người ta không dùng
đâu. Người ta dùng lbm cơ. Đây này.
Người ta dùng đây này. Cái mô hình nó
khác đi đúng không? Thế các bạn thay đi.
Tất nhiên là cái implementation ở bên
trong nó cũng sẽ khác một chút chứ nó
cũng nó cũng không giống 100% như mình
làm ở đây đâu. Đấy nhưng mà cách về mặt
bản chất thì nó tương đương nhau. Về mặt
bản nhất tương đương nhau. Đấy thì sau
này ấ khi các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ làm
như này. Dùng cái này cho nó nhanh đúng
không? Chứ còn chả mấy ai người ta lại
có sức người ta ngồi người ta ngồi bẻ
này t ra thật ra thì cái này nó cũng chả
có lâu. Thế nhưng mà ông nào tiện hơn
thì chúng ta dùng thôi. Đấy nhưng mà khi
mà các bạn tự các bạn tự làm tự code
theo ý hiểu tự code từng bước một này
thì các bạn sẽ hiểu cái bản chất ở bên
trong rõ hơn. Còn nếu mà các bạn vừa vào
phát các bạn đột lột vào đấy luôn ấy thì
các bạn sẽ không biết là ở bên trong nó
có cái gì nó xảy ra. Được chưa? Đ không
nó sẽ có recourship nó sẽ có direct này.
Nó cũng tương tự như nhau thôi đúng
không? Input được vào các bạn thay đổi
mỗi cái tên thôi. Đây ông này gọi là for
đây gọi là forecaster direct được chưa?
Ông kia thì gọi là ông kia thì là gọi là
forecaster recursive chưa? Có hai cách
như vậy. Nó còn có thêm nhiều một vài
cái một cái vài cái thứ ở dưới nó cũng
khá là hay. Nếu có thời gian thì thì mấy
cái buổi cuối mình sẽ quay lại cái
report này một lần nữa nhá.
Rồi thì đấy là đấy là về recursif. Thì
bây gi chúng ta chúng ta đã có requ
chúng ta muốn bẻ nó sang thành direct
thì cũng rất là dễ thôi. Bỏ sang direct
rất là dễ. Các bạn nhớ là direct về
recip nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi cái đoạn là
gì? là một ông là tôi dùng đây này
recitive là tôi dùng đúng một mô hình
thôi còn par của tôi sẽ dùng nhiều mô
hình đúng không bạn cách làm nó nó sẽ
khác nhau một chút xíu nhưng về mặt bản
chất nó sẽ tương đương nhau tức là nó có
rất nhiều đoạn nó giống nhau ví dụ nhá
mình ví dụ cho các bạn xem thử nhá ví dụ
nhá bây giờ mình sẽ từ đây đi mình sẽ
copy đ mình tạo cái script mới nhá mình
sẽ không phải viết lại hoàn toàn mất
thời gian lắm thì copy này nhá mình sẽ
thêm cái nữa là direct này đúng không
mình sẽ direct nhá
direct như này nhá để cho Direct đấy
đúng không? Tắt này đi. Tắt này đi. Được
chưa? Direct thì bây giờ
đổi một vài thứ đúng không? Mấy cái a
mấy cái chỗ này thì à
Visual thì cũng không cần nữa đúng
không? Visual không cần trên Visual rồi.
Tách dữ liệu thì thì đã tính xong cái
chỗ fit phủng với cái chỗ tr này mình
xóa bớt đi nhá. Tí mình làm viết lại
này.
C đến đây đã. Ờ chỗ này thì cũng chưa
cần ngay
được chưa? Bây giờ chỗ create nhá. Đúng
không? Cái này gọi là direct đi. Direct
đi cho tên nó khác đi. Được chưa? Thì
bây giờ ấy
đúng không các bạn? Nhìn này. Cái dữ
liệu dành cho cái cách tiếp cận direct
với cả cái recorship nó khác nhau là ở
chỗ nào? Nó khác nhau ở chỗ là là
với cái recorship ấy là thật ra các bạn
chỉ có luyện một mô hình thôi. Recourip
các bạn huấn luyện một mô hình đúng
không? Input đầu vào nó cứ dịch một dịch
1 dịch một như vậy đúng không? Và đấy
chính là cách chúng ta tạo ra bộ rượu
chúng ta. Chúng ta cứ dịch một, dịch
một, dịch một chúng ta tạo ra những cái
mới. Thế còn về cái direct này ấy, về
mặt bản chất của direct là gì? Là tôi sẽ
huấn luyện nhiều mô hình. Đồng thời, các
cái mô hình này nó sẽ có cùng input đầu
vào. Nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi cái output đầu
ra thôi, đúng không? Một ông là ông, một
ông là cái tiếp theo, một cái ông tiếp
theo nữa. Tiếp theo nữa đúng không? Đấy,
tức là ví dụ ba đây, tôi dùng cái mô
hình tôi dựa vào lượng CO2 của 5 tuần
thì tôi dựa cho ba tuần ba tuần tiếp đi
đúng không? Thì năm thì thì tôi sẽ có ba
mô hình. Ba mô hình này cùng nhận input
giống y hiệt nhau. Nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi
đồ ra thôi là mỗi ông là một cột dịch
tiếp theo đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ
làm tương tự ở đây đúng không? Bây giờ
khiển tạo rượu này tôi sẽ phải có thêm
tham số Windows size này đúng không? Tit
size
bằng 3 đi được chưa? Windows size này.
Tit size này được chưa? Windows size
này. Tit size nhá.
Mai nhá. Được chưa? Windows size này.
Tit size này được chưa? Tạo ra Windows,
tạo ra cái input thì không có vấn đề gì
nhưng bây giờ mình sẽ phải tạo thêm ra
cái output phải tạo ra nhiều nhiều hơn.
Tôi phải tạo ra nhiều cái tag hit hơn
chứ không chỉ có một cái như này đúng
không? Thì tôi lại là một cái vòng lặp
như này. Được chưa? Bây giờ tôi sẽ
lúc trước là tôi cho y chạy từ 1 tại vì
là tôi đã có sẵn cột CO2 gốc rồi. Nhưng
mà về target tôi chưa có cái gốc nào cả
thì tôi cho cho chạy từ 0 đúng không? y
bằng 0 cho lại cũng y
nhỏ hơn các si như này đúng không? I nhỏ
hơn tit size này sau tôi sẽ bắt đầu tôi
sẽ lại làm lọc trong thôi đúng không?
Đây này
đúng không? Tôi sẽ không gọi target
không nữa. Tôi sẽ gọi target
tit như này. Đúng chưa?
For cho cái i vào đây. Được chưa? Bây
giờ shift tôi sẽ tôi sẽ không chỉ shift
trừ Windows size tôi sẽ trừ window size
trừ tiếp thì y này được chưa? Như b ờ
dưới là y + 1 này được chưa? Tôi bây giờ
tôi sẽ tạo ra nhiều cột tit hơn chứ tôi
không chỉ tạo ra một nữa. Được chưa? Bây
giờ chạy thử nhá. Đúng không? Tôi thêm
cái phần này đúng không? Lúc trước tôi
chỉ tạo ra một target rồi đúng không các
bạn? Nhìn này. Lúc trước là tôi chỉ tạo
ra một target thôi. Re
đúng không? Lúc trước tôi chỉ tạo ra một
target thôi, còn giờ tôi t tạo ra nhiều
target. Được chưa?
À đây sẽ như target ở dưới này chứ. Đây
target size đây. Được chưa? Đấy chạy thử
nhá. Chạy thử nhá. Bây giờ mình chạy chỗ
này này.
Đây nhá.
ch lại này
thì có phải là bây giờ các bạn thấy đây
đây đúng không?
Cột time thì cái cột thời gian vẫn thế
chả khác gì đúng không? CO2, CO21, CO22,
CO23, C24. Đây là năm cái fature đầu
vào. Ba mô hình mình sẽ dùng chung cái
năm ông này. Nó chỉ khác trong một cái
tác đầu ra thôi, đúng không? Một ông thì
đây 36,9 đây. Đúng không? Tiếp 37,2 đây.
37,5 đây. Được chưa? Cứ tiếp tục như vậy
được chưa?
Thế
ờ được chưa? Thế bây giờ mình tức là bây
giờ ba mô hình của mình nó sẽ chung
input khác nhau output thôi. Được chưa?
Bây giờ cái đoạn tách target này nó sẽ
khác đi một tí. Lúc trước là mình chỉ có
một cái target thì dễ rồi. Bây giờ mình
có nhiều target hơn. Được chưa? Mình có
nhiều target hơn thì bây giờ mình sẽ lúc
mà drop ấy tôi sẽ drop nhiều hơn. Cái
cột time là một nhá. Đúng không? Bây giờ
ví dụ mình có một cái nữa là tis nhiều
đi đúng không? Bằng cái gì? bằng
tagit und như này
format e
for in của
size này nhá.
Tôi bỏ bỏ tôi sẽ bỏ như này cộng hai ông
này vào nhau được chưa? Lấy thì tôi cũng
chỉ lấy ông này thôi.
Được chưa? bỏ tôi sẽ bỏ x tôi sẽ bỏ cột
time với cả ba cái cột target đi. Còn y
tôi sẽ lấy ba cột tit thôi. Đen này cứ
làm từng bước cứ kiểm tra xem có cái gì
có vấn đề không. Chạy thử này.
Đây nhá. X đây. X đây. Được chưa?
Y đây. Đấy. Y đúng ba cột này. Được
chưa? Đấy cách là x với y rồi.
Được chưa? X Y rồi mấy cái bước dưới
đựng tương tự thôi. Lại cũng chuyên sai
các thứ này. Chuyên sai đây. Được chưa?
Chỗ này cũng thế.
Tách ra đây chỗ này chả khác gì cả đúng
không? Tách ra. Nhưng mà chú ý là bây
giờ Y bây giờ không Y bây giờ không còn
là một cột nữa mà nó sẽ nhiều cột.
Y không còn là một cột nữa mà sẽ nhiều
cột.
Đây nhá các bạn chưa? Y với nó là ba cột
này. Được chưa? Đấy sau khi các bạn có
cái Y này rồi các bạn lại đấy lại tương
tự bây giờ các bạn đưa vào trong mô hình
thôi. Nhưng mà bây giờ các bạn chú ý
này. Bây giờ các bạn sẽ không phải các
bạn chỉ có một mô hình mà các bạn sẽ có
nhiều mô hình. Được chưa? Ví dụ đây các
bạn có ba mô hình. Về mặt kỹ thuật ba mô
hình này có thể là ba mô hình khác nhau.
Có thể cái ông một ông là linear
reaction, một ông là random forest một
là support better machine hoàn toàn ok
đúng không? hoặc các bạn cũng có thể sử
dụng cùng một mô hình. Thì thật ra các
bạn chú ý này, thật ra ấy đối với tất cả
các cái mô hình trong sách kỹ lon ấy ví
dụ nhá linear regression này,
thật ra đối với tất cả những cái mô hình
này
ờ
thật ra ấy với tất cả những mô hình các
bạn chú ý này, với tất cả những cái mô
hình này ấ cái
cái x thì không làm gì nhưng mà cái y ý
thông thường khi chúng ta dùng y chúng
ta chỉ cho một cái cột tác xí thôi đúng
đúng không? Thì nếu các bạn chỉ cho một
cột tí thôi thì nó sẽ rơi vào cái nó rơi
vào cái trường hợp này. Tức là ví dụ các
bạn có 100 sample thì các bạn sẽ các bạn
sẽ đưa vào một cái một cái array có 100
phần tử đúng không? Thông thường là
chúng ta chỉ có một target. Thế nhưng mà
thật ra ấy thì tất cả các cái class
trong se ấy người ta đều thiết kế để các
bạn có thể làm việc được với nhiều
target. Tức là gì? Các bạn có thể dùng
một cùng cái mô hình này các bạn dự đoán
nhiều cái target khác nhau thì nó sẽ cái
bài trượp thứ hai N sample N target này.
Được chưa? Các bạn có nhiều các bạn có
nhiều target hơn các bạn cho vào đây
được chưa?
Đấy, ví dụ các bạn có 1000 sample, mỗi
mỗi simple các bạn có ba cái target. Đây
n target này chính là trong trường này
chính là 3 đấy. Đúng không? Chính là 3
đấy. Đúng không? Đấy. Đó, chiều này nó
ít xảy ra hơn. Ví dụ, ví dụ các bạn
tưởng tượng này, các bạn muốn sử dụng
cái mô hình để dự án vừa dự đoán giá
nhà, vừa dự đoán a vị trí của nhà, ví dụ
như vậy, đúng không? Thì đấy nó chữ cái
mô hình mà các bạn sẽ có nhiều hơn một
tí. Đấy thì các bạn hoàn toàn các bạn có
thể đưa các bạn nếu mà các bạn dùng ba
mô hình giống y hiệt nhau ví dụ đều là
linear re ấy thì các bạn thật về mặt kỹ
thuật các bạn có thể hoàn toàn các bạn
đưa luôn cả cái x truyền với x test này
vào là hoàn toàn ok. Thế nhưng mà như
mình nói thì trong thực tế là có thể ba
mô hình nó còn nó có thể là ba mô hình
nó khác nhau nên ở đây mình sẽ coi như
mình đang dùng tại vì mình muốn làm cái
trường hợp tổng quát để cho mình có thể
đưa vào nhiều mô hình khác nhau đúng
không? Ví dụ bây giờ mình cho txic của
mình ví dụ cái mô hình question đi đúng
không? Giả sử ở đây sẽ là linear
question này đúng không? Ví dụ một này
đúng không? Ví dụ
đúng không? For in
sai đúng không? Như mình nói rồi. Thật
ra ở đây mình dùng ba mình giống nhau
nên là mình có thể mình chỉ dùng đúng
một cái mô hình linear là xong. Nhưng mà
thôi đây mình cứ dượt tổng quát tại vì
là có thể nó sẽ là nhiều mô hình khác
nhau. Được chưa? Đây mình có ba mô hình
nhá. Đúng không? Ba mô hình giống hiện
nhau này. Đây mình bạn nhá. Này
nhá.
Được chưa? này.
Đấy ba mình này được chưa? Thế bây giờ
mình xem là mình fit thôi. Fit thì fit
thì fit như bình thường thôi đúng không?
Bây giờ for này for red này. In red này
được chưa? Này được chưa? For red này
mình sẽ để fit này. Thì fit này mà có
một điều chú ý này là cái ấy bây giờ ấy
mình muốn là gì? Mình muốn là ở đây có
thể mình có ba mô hình linear reaction
không? Thì mình muốn là cái mô hình đầu
tiên sẽ dùng cái sẽ dùng cái tagit 0.
Cái mô hình thứ hai dùng cái tagit 1 và
mô hình cuối dùng cái tagit 2 đúng
không? Tức là gì? Trong cái này nó có ba
cột đúng không? Một cột là target 0,
target 1 và tit 2. Thế bây giờ mình muốn
là gì? Bây giờ với cái mô hình red đầu
tiên dùng tagit 0, mô hình red thứ hai
tx1, mô hình cuối tx2 thì mình phải làm
thế nào bây giờ? Làm sao tôi tách ra
được
bây giờ? Làm sao để tôi tách ra được?
Tôi lấy được cái ông đầu tiên là tit0,
ông thứ hai tit 1, cuối tx2. Làm thế nào
bây giờ? Ví dụ ở đây đúng không?
Tit chẳng hạn đúng không? Tôi để thêm
cái này nữ mà làm sao tôi biết là tôi
lấy cái nào bây giờ? Làm thế nào bây
giờ?
Lấy bằng cách nào đây?
Làm thế nào bây giờ? Làm sao để lấy được
cái chỉ số đúng? Bây giờ làm sao để lấy
đúng cái ông đầu tiên thì lấy được cái
target 0. Ông ha tet 1 ông có tet 2. Lấy
kiểu gì bây giờ?
À chỉ một cách lấy nào. Nó chỉ lập trình
Python thuần túy thôi
đúng không? Bao phải có ba cái khác
nhau.
Làm thủ công như siêu cộng set bị. Ui
giời ơi.
Ừ. Đây format đây. Ừ. Format mà format
nhét cái gì vào bây giờ đúng format.
Nhưng mà nhét cái gì vào format bây giờ?
Y đâu? Làm gì có y? Làm gì có y ở đây
đâu
cái này á.
Y = 0.
Y ở đây y 1 á. Cái này được. Cách này
thì được nhưng mà
nhưng mà có cách đơn giản hơn đúng
không? Có cách đơn giản hơn đúng không?
Cách này thì thì thì thì thì phổ biến
quá rồi.
Có cách nào đơn giản hơn không? Phải tạo
ra một biến y mới rồi cộng 1. Hơi phức
tạp.
Có cách nào đơn giản không các bạn?
Đây là câu hỏi kiểm tra xem các bạn lập
trình Python có đủ nhiều không đấy. Xem
có lập trình Python có đủ nhiều không
đấy hay là chỉ quen P code thôi.
Ai biết làm cái nào không?
Dễ lắm các bạn này. Dễ lắm luôn. Bạn nào
mà các bạn đã từng tự code tự code
Python đã từng tự học code Python rồi
chắc các bạn phải biết cách này.
y - 3 gi y trừ -3 - 1 á
2.3
ok không có begin có last có step
không
ạ. Thế
đơn giản lắm các bạn khác thì sao?
Không có cách này
vai code nhiều quá bây giờ code chay là
chịu rồi.
Cộng á. Ừ thì cái này thì nó đúng thật
nhưng mà trong Python có đơn giản hơn
các bạn ạ. Trong Python bạn nào các bạn
đã từng code Python rồi, bạn từng học
code Python rồi nó có cách khác đơn giản
hơn.
Hàm cực kỳ basic luôn. Hàm cực kỳ basic
luôn. lớp không ai biết có cách nào khác
à.
Đúng rồi, dùng enumerate đúng không?
Thật ra ấy nếu mà bảo là nếu mà bảo là
đây là dùng C nhá thì thậm chí các bạn
nếu mà bảo dùng C có cộng các bạn còn
chẳng cò này. Các các bạn chỉ làm gì?
Các bạn dùng là Y+ C++ là xong đúng
không?
Y+ cộng ừ đúng không? Thôi các bạn dùng
y+ cộng này đúng không? Các bạn còn chả
cần phải có cái dòng ở dưới đúng không?
Python nó không có nhưng mà trong y đ Y
tức là dùng y rồi mới cộng lên đúng
không? Nhưng mà cần gì thế này không
dùng enumerate đúng không? Dùng
enumerate đây I này enumerate nàyate
nào đơn giản hơn nhiều đúng không?
Enumerate này m vào đây này xong này
được chưa?
enumerate
thôi các bạn cũng là thể các bạn đánh
giá mô hình được đúng không? Đánh giá mô
hình đây là fit nhá đúng không các bạn?
Đánh giá mô hình thì bây giờ trước khi
đánh giá mô hình các bạn làm ba cái list
này r đúng không? Một cái list nhá được
chưa? Min square root nhá đúng không?
Rồi min square root nhá. Được chưa? Tôi
sẽ làm ba cái list này. Ba cái list để
lưu để lưu lưu lưu trữ cái score cho ba
cái magic này đúng không? Coefficient là
determination này. Min absolute root này
với cả mean square root. Được chưa? Mình
bắt đầu lại lắp tiếp for e
chứ in enumerate tiếp này được chưa? Bây
giờ phải là e predict copy nhá
nhá bằng red. Predict này đúng không?
Predict này là x
chưa?
Được chưa? Sao mình lại à mấy cái score
đây? Rồi
đấy. Vậy sa này nhỏ quá thôi. Rồi làm
sao đây đúng up and
đúng không?
Mình sẽ cho mình sẽ cho là đây là it
đúng không? Lấy từ đúng cột này. Yx này
được chưa?
Min squad thì lấy
min
được chưa? Min square thì cũng tương tự
như vậy chư. Min square root này đúng
không? Min
root này. Được chưa?
Tất nhiên là càng hằng sau thì sau dưới
mình sẽ in ra in ra print
print là square store chưa
có này
được chưa
min này min đây
đây min square Erot
thử đây.
Được chưa các bạn? Nhìn này.
Các bạn thấy là gì? Bạn thấy là rõ ràng
là rõ ràng đúng không? Càng càng cái ông
ở xa thì cái điểm nó càng bớt chính xác
đi đúng không? Điều hiển nhiên đúng
không? Càng hổ xa càng chính xác đi đúng
không? Đây là mình dự đoán cho bán giá
trị trong tương lai. Còn các bạn muốn dự
đoán nhiều hơn thì nó cũng tương tự như
vậy thôi đúng không? Đấy mà tất nhiên là
đây là các bạn đây là chúng ta tự code
để chúng ta hiểu bản chất thôi. Còn các
bạn trong thực tế các bạn dùng các bạn
dùng cái thực viện như mình vừa mới nói
rồi đây. Các bạn dùng gì bạn cổ vào phát
là xong các bạn chả phải convert gì.
Dùng cái thư viện này các bạn không phải
không phải ngồi các bạn tạo ra cái hàm
thủ công này nó sẽ tự làm cho các bạn
luôn. Được chưa?
Thế thôi đúng không? Đây là bài toán
time series for casting đúng không? Dự
đoán chuỗi thời gian đúng không? Đây là
hai cái tiết kận cơ bản sau này có nhiều
cái khác nó sẽ phối hợp ra cách này
nhưng mà nó đều được sự dựa trên cái
base này thôi. Nó có thể nó phối hợp
thêm một vài những cái bước hậu post
processing nữa để cho nó cải thiện
performance. Nhưng mà nhìn chung là cái
ý tưởng gốc nó vẫn như thế này. Được
chưa? Rồi ok. Lớp có bạn nào có câu hỏi
gì không?
Thế thì nhân tiện ở đây đã nói về những
cái thư viện ngoài, những cái thư viện
được xây dựng để bổ trợ cho cy kì nó
cũng có rất nhiều những cái thư viện thì
nó được xây dựng nó tức là không phải nó
không phải là bổ trợ mà nó là có những
thư viện nó mở rộng nó thêm những cái
thuật toán những cái mô hình mà s chưa
có. Thì ở đây mình sẽ lịch cái bạn hai
thư viện, hai framework nhất là boot.
Đây là thiện nó đã quá nó đã nó đã quá
nổi tiếng rồi. Exibus là cái phiên bản ờ
mở rộng nó thì thứ nhất là nó tập trung
vào những cái nó tập trung vào những cái
thự nh vào và vào và vào nhóm các cái th
toán boosting. Nên các bạn nhớ hôm nọ
mình nói các bạn là ờ trong trong
machining ấy nó có nó có một nhóm các
cái thuật toán người ta gọi nó là
learning. Ansemble learning có nghĩa là
gì? Asable learning có nghĩa là những
cái thuật toán mà tôi sẽ dùng nhiều tôi
sẽ kết hợp nhiều thuật toán nhỏ để tôi
được một cái mô hình thuậ toán nó lớn
hơn đúng không? Ví dụ trong AC Learning
nó sẽ có nó sẽ có hai
thật ra là nó có bốn nhóm nó có bốn nhóm
nhưng mà sẽ có hai cái nhóm phổ biến
nhất cho các bạn một là backing. Backing
như này
backing ví dụ mình có nhiều mô hình ví
dụ backing ví dụ random fr chính là
backing đấy đúng không? Chúng ta có một
bộ rượu lớn, chúng ta tách nó thành
những cái bộ rượu con đúng không? Th
tách thành cái bộ rượu con. Mỗi bộ rượu
nó ví dụ là khoảng 70% của bộ gốc ban
đầu. Được chưa? Mỗ bộ dư con này mình
cho qua một cái mô hình. Mô hình của
mình đây. Model ở đây. Model ở đây.
Nhưng cái mô hình này thường là những
cái mô hình nó rất là nhỏ, rất là độ chứ
hạn nó không cao luôn. Ví dụ là DC. Sau
đó tôi kết hợp cái dự đoán chúng lại kết
hợp lại thành một cái cuối cùng đúng
không? Thì cái cách tự cận này người ta
gọi là backing. Backing được chưa? Cái
tự thứ hai là gì? là cái backing này thì
mỗi một cái mô hình con cái yếu tố then
chốt là gì? Là các cái mô hình con này
thứ nhất là nó sẽ cùng một kiểu. Ví dụ
thường nó là cùng là DC chẳng hạn và thứ
hai là chúng sẽ phải được huấn luyện
trên các cái bộ rượu con khác nhau. Tức
là ông này phải khác với ông này phải
ông này đúng không? Chúng nó phải khác
nhau thì nó mới có cái sự đa dạng trong
cái cái dự đoán. Chứ còn chúng nó giống
yệt nhau thì thì thì thì thì 10 hay là
100 mô hình nó cũng dựa yệt nhau chả có
tác dụng gì cả. Được chưa? Đây gọi là
backing.
Backing nhá. Đây gọi là backing.
Được chưa? Cái thứ hai người ta gọi là
boosting.
Boosting
boost là tăng lên đấy. Đúng không? Về
boosting nó sẽ kiểu như này là các bạn
sẽ có một cái mô hình gốc à một cái bộ
rượu gốc này. Data đây data này các bạn
sẽ dùng nó để các bạn huấn luyện cái mô
hình đầu tiên model 1. Model 1 này nó sẽ
đưa ra cái dự đoán thì những cái dự đoán
của nó sẽ có những cái dự đoán đúng và
dự đoán sai đúng không? Mình sẽ phân lầm
hai loại nhá. Một cái là những cái dự án
đúng, một cái là những cái dự án sai.
Thế bây giờ ấy lần thứ sau khi mô hình
một được huấn luyện xong ấy thì cái lần
mà chúng ta dùng vẫn dùng cái dữ liệu
này chúng ta hố lệ cái mô hình thứ hai
ấy thì những cái sample nào mà mô hình
một nó đã dự đoán sai rồi ấy thì khi mà
tôi đưa những cái s này vào cái mô hình
hai tôi sẽ tăng cái trọng số của nó lên.
Tăng trọng số nghĩa là tôi sẽ tăng cái
tầm quan trọng của nó lên. Tức là tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ bắt mô hình của tôi nó sẽ phải
focus nhiều hơn vào những cái sample này
và những cái sle mà cái ông đi trước nó
sai ấy. Đúng không? Giống kiểu các bạn
là bây giờ các bạn giống kiểu là bây giờ
tôi huấn luyện cho 10 đứa trẻ. Đứa đầu
đứa đầu tiên nó sẽ huấn luyện với toàn
bộ dữ liệu đúng không? Nó sẽ có những
cái dự án đúng, dự án sai. Cái đứa thứ
hai ấy tôi vẫn dạy nó với toàn bộ dữ
liệu nhưng mà những cái những cái
những cái câu hỏi nào mà cái đứa đầu
tiên nó đã sai ấ thì cái đứa thứ hai nó
sẽ phải focus hơn vào đấy. Mình sẽ cho
ví dụ là các bạn cho cái câu hỏi nó tăng
trọng số lên. Ví dụ bình thường cái đứa
đầu tiên là câu nào cũng một điểm thì
cái đứa thứ hai là những câu mà cái ông
đầu tiên ông đấy sai nó sẽ cho là hai
điểm. Tôi sẽ bắt m phải focus đấy vào
hơn. Tức là cứ hôm sau nó sẽ phải focus
hơn cái những cái thứ mà cái ông ngay
trước nó vừa sai. Do đến cuối tôi cũng
sẽ tổng hợp kết quả của tất cả những âm
này lại. Thì đây người ta gọi là
boosting. Thế thì cái framework exbut
này nó tập trung vào cái toán boosting.
Như vậy cách dùng thì thật ra cách dùng
nó gần như nó nó y chang với size
killer. Các bạn dùng y chang chả khác gì
cả. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Đây nhá.
Đây dùng nó nó chả khác gì cả. Đây
đây các bạn nhìn này. Thấy chưa? dùng có
khác gì đâu đúng không? Đầu tiên là cũng
có dữ liệu nhá. Đây là người ta dùng cái
bộ rượu về ung thư vú. Bộ rượu về ung
thư vú là các bạn không có bộ rượu này
các bạn dùng cái bộ của chúng ta chả
khác gì cả đúng không? Chúng ta dùng cái
bộ David, bộ Score chả khác gì cả đúng
không? Cũng có X đúng không? Đây người
ta tách sẵn cái bộ này người ta tách sẵn
X đi rồi còn đây không mình phải tách tự
tách ra đ x/ Yên các thứ này đúng không?
Đây dùng thư viện này cũng như này được
chưa? Cũng fit phủng các thứ này cũng
chả khác gì cả chả khác gì đúng không?
Early stopping là cái gì? Early stopping
nó là một cái kỹ thuật. Cái này thật ra
các bạn sẽ gặp sau này các bạn nào các
bạn học tiếp cái khóa sau các bạn học về
deep lear deep learning ấy các bạn sẽ
nói nhiều về kỹ thuật này nhiều hơn. Ely
stoping nó như này
các bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Thông thường ấy
với các cái thuật toán machining truyền
thống thì các bạn không cần phải dùng
early stopping. Tại vì sao? Tại vì các
cái thuật toán machine truyền thống là
những cái thuật toán chúng ta học từ
đầuến giờ cho đến giờ ấy là những cái
thuật toán mà nó rất là đơn giản. Nó đơn
giản thế nên là cái quá trình huấn luyện
nó rất là nhanh. các bạn chỉ mấy giây
các bạn đã huấn luyện xong rồi nên là
nên là nó rất là dễ. Thế nhưng mà sau
này khi mà các bạn học về những ví dụ
các bạn dùng cái mô hình trong exbost
này các bạn có rất nhiều dữ liệu, các
bạn có vài triệu record đi hoặc là các
bạn dùng những cái mô hình trong deep
learning chẳng hạn cái mô hình mà
huấn luyện nó rất là lâu. Thì bây giờ
nếu mà cứ để huấn luyện lâu mãi như vậy
ấ thì nó mất thời gian. Thế bây giờ ấy
cái cái ý tưởng của early stopping là
gì? Tức là tôi sẽ có những thời điểm tôi
sẽ dự đoán được rằng nếu tôi có
chuyên tiếp thì khả năng cao là tôi cũng
không có được mô hình tốt hơn. Khả năng
cao tôi không được mô hình tốt hơn thì
tôi sẽ dừng sớm đi. Tại vì tôi cứ trên
mã trên mãi trên mã như vậy. Mình lấy
một cái ví dụ cho bạn nhá. Mình lấy cho
bạn một cái ví dụ đi. Ví dụ như lớp mình
ví dụ các bạn các bạn đi học I chẳng hạn
đúng không? Lúc ban đầu các bạn vạch ra
kế hoạch là gì? Là tôi sẽ học I trong 3
năm. Được chưa? Tôi học I trong 3 năm.
Tôi cứ học từng tháng từng tháng một và
cứ cuối một tháng tôi sẽ đi thi thử được
chưa? Cứ cuối 1 tháng tôi sẽ đi thi thử
tôi học trong 3 năm liền được chưa? Thế
nhưng mà học 3 năm thì nó sẽ lâu. Thì
bây giờ tôi sẽ ra một cái quy tôi ra một
cái quy tắc này. Tôi ra một cái quy tắc
là nếu tức là cứ hết một tháng tôi đi
thi thử một lần để tôi xem là cái quá
trình tôi đang học nó đến đâu đúng
không? Thì bây giờ ra một cái quy luật
này là gì? Nếu mà tôi thấy là kết quả
thi thử của tôi trong 3 tháng liên tiếp
mà không có sự cải thiện thì tôi sẽ dừng
luôn, tôi đi thi thật luôn. Tôi sẽ không
học nữa. Tại vì nếu tôi thấy là 3 tháng
liền mà mình học kết quả nó không tốt
hơn thì học tiếp nó cũng nó cũng không
có giúp gì hơn. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được
chưa? Thì đấy đấy chính là cái ý tưởng
của đấy chính là cái ý tưởng của của
early stopping. Đấy các bạn học deing nó
sẽ rất quan trọng tại về việcing ấy các
bạn huấn luyện một cái mô hình nó có để
hết vài ngày trời. Các bạn cứ để một vài
ngày như vậy mà tôi cứ huấn luyện tôi cứ
để nó chạy hết như vậy nó rất là lâu
đúng tôi sẽ tìm cái thời điểm mà đấy ví
dụ là tôi thấy là trong một khoảng thời
gian rồi tôi thấy mô hình của tôi nó
không có được cải thiện so với trước thì
tôi sẽ dừng luôn. Được chưa?
Rồi thế bạn dùng cái này rất là đơn giản
không nó được tích hợp trong cái hệ sinh
thái của cyc bạn dùng rất là dễ không
kết hợp hai thư viện với nhau tại vì
thật ra về mặt bản chất ấy ở bên trong
cái exbut này nó cũng gọi những cái
class những cái thứ của cơn mà nó sẽ dự
trong cái hệ sinh thái này nên là các
bạn dùng thượng nó rất là dễ đúng không
thư viện về cân bằng dữ liệu này thư
viện về bài toán time save for casting
này rồi này nó được xự trên cái nền của
cycler là cái thứ nhất cái thứ hai nữa
một cái thư viện khác nữa là line gpm lb
bịp
đây nhá.
Đây thực hiện thứ hai đây. Tức là nó
cũng nó cũng thế. Nó cũng thế các bạn
cũng có thể các bạn sẽ dùng nó cùng với
à cái exibut về cái gp này nó có một cái
ưu điểm so với k là gì? Là c ấy nó không
dùng góp này dùng g được.
L gpm với cả exibut là dùng được. Dùng
JPU nó sẽ tăng tốc cái quá trình các bạn
ấn lại lên. Các bạn tận dụng tài nguyên
phần cứng. Thế còn se thì chịu sách cái
lơn các bạn bắt buộc các bạn phải dùng
CPU thôi. Được chưa
nhá? Ok. Bạn có câu hỏi gì không? Bạn có
thắc mắc gì không?
Ok. Thế nếu mà không ai thắc mắc gì
chúng ta sang phần tiếp theo các bạn
nhá.
Ờ chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sang tiếp cái
phần tiếp cái phần lý thuyết chúng ta
đang dừng lại hôm nọ.
Đây hôm nọ chúng ta đang dừng lại cái
đoạn chúng ta nói về
chọn các cái mô hình machining dựa trên
dữ liệu đúng không? Cho nói việc là mô
hình dữ liệu nếu mà dữ nhiều hàng ít cột
thì như thế nào? Ít ít hàng nhiều cột
thì như thế nào? Nhiều cả hai nha kiểu
như vậy đúng không?
Như và hôm nọ mình nói rồi cái slide này
ấ nó chỉ phụ cho các bạn trong bạn đi
trở về phỏng vấn thôi. Trả phỏng vấn các
bạn sẽ phải người ta sẽ đưa các bạn một
cái bộ rượu bạn phải phân tích là à rượu
tôi thế này thế này, nhiều hàng ít cột,
nhiều cột ít hàng tôi phải dùng mô hình
này kiểu kiểu như vậy. Thế nhưng mà khi
mà các bạn đi làm ấy các bạn chỉ đơn
giản các bạn chạy ví dụ các bạn chạy
lazy PR chẳng hạn chạy một lúc mấy chục
mô hình đúng không là xong rồi đúng
không? Chả cần phải ngồi nghĩ nhiều. Trừ
phi các bạn có quá nhiều dữ liệu, quá
trình huấn luyện nó lâu quá thì còn phải
cân nhắc, còn không thì các bạn cứ chạy
lazy break là xong. Được chưa? Thế nhưng
mà chọn mô hình dựa trên dữ liệu nó chỉ
một cái khí hạnh rất là nhỏ thôi. Đây
thông thường sẽ là cái mà các bạn sẽ
được dạy trên các cái chương trình đào
tạo chính quy trên các dần đ trên sản
đại học. Tức là gì? Tôi chọn tôi chọn mô
hình dựa vào cái dữ liệu của tôi. Thế
nhưng mà sau này khi mà các bạn đi làm
ấy thì các bạn sẽ cần phải cân nhắc cái
việc là các bạn chọn mô hình dựa vào cái
business domain của cái công ty của các
bạn. Tức là cái mảng lĩnh vực của công
ty các bạn. Tức là gì? Như đầu tiên là
chúng ta phải quan tâm xem là chúng ta
sẽ cần magic gì. Như mình đã nói rồi cái
hôm chúng ta học về các cái magic ấy
đúng không? Giả sử ở đây mình giả sử ở
đây đúng không? Mình đã nói về bài toán
classification đi đúng không? Thì các
bạn biết là trong classification đúng có
rất nhiều matric khác nhau. Cái tiêu
biểu nhất thì là acasy. Thế nhưng mà ac
là nó là một cái magic mà gần như sau
này các bạn đi làm các bạn sẽ trả cơ hội
dùng. Thì đơn giản rượu ngoài đời lúc
nào nó cũng mất cân bằng. nó rất mất cân
bằng nên là dùng acas nó chả có nhiều ý
nghĩa được chưa? Tương tự như vậy và với
request các bạn dùng là dùng thông
thường ta sẽ dùng coefficient of of
determination đúng không các bạn? Cũng
cũng có thể các bạn dùng means hoặ là
min square thì các bạn muốn cái nó có
tính chất nó giải thích nó dễ hơn đúng
không? Thế thế nhưng mà đấy chỉ một yếu
tố rất là nhỏ thôi.
Sau này khi bạn đi làm các bạn phải
tưởng tượng này. Khi mà các bạn đi học á
bao gồm các bạn học cái khóa này của
mình và các bạn học ở trên trường đại
học chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì ví dụ các
bạn học trên trường đi. Cái một cái
project các bạn sử dụng về machining
hoặc là về AI nó sẽ như nào? Dây là thầy
cho các bạn một cái đề tài đúng không?
Thầy có thể cho các bạn dữ liệu, các bạn
có thể các bạn làm việc với dữ liệu đó.
Các bạn huấn luyện mô hình, mô hình bạn
dự đoán được ra kết quả đúng không? Và
thông thường thầy sẽ chấm điểm dựa về
cái việc gì? là mô hình của bạn ấy nó
dết quả nó càng chính xác thì càng tốt.
Thậm chí cả các cái cuộc thi nó cũng như
thế thôi. Các cái cuộc thi kiểu
cái cuộc thi về data sen thế họ cũng sẽ
chỉ cân đánh giá cái việc là mô hình các
bạn nó dự đoán nó chính xác về thực tế
thôi. Mỗi như vậy thôi. Và khi ở trên
trường môn hình các bạn dán chính xác
xong thầy cho điểm xong thầy về nhà thầy
trò về nhà trò không ai quan tâm là cái
mô hình này nó sẽ dùng ở đâu, sẽ dùng
tiếp như thế nào đúng không? Nhưng đây
là một cái điểm mà nó
đây chính là cái điểm nó khác biệt giữa
môi trường làm việc thực tế và môi
trường gọi là nghiên cứu học thuật đúng
không? Nghiên cứu học thuật thì người ta
gọi nó là academic environment đúng
không? Thế còn môi trường academic
environment còn môi trường thực tế người
ta gọi là industrial environment.
Industrial là môi trường các bạn sẽ làm
ở công ty các bạn phải làm sản phẩm các
bạn bán cho khách hàng đúng không? Cho
người khác người ta sử dụng được đúng
không?
chút
các bạn chờ mình xíu nhá.
Thế thế thì các bạn tưởng tượng nhá, nó
không nó không có ba thệ kia nó không có
cái nào không có cái nào gọi là chung
chung tốt hơn cái nào đâu. Từng bài to
cụ thể mình sẽ phải thử phải thử thôi
chứ còn nó tại vì bây giờ nếu mà có ông
nào tốt nhất thì hai ông kia chết từ lâu
rồi đúng không? Mỗi ông nó sẽ có những
cái ưu điểm khác nhau. Ví dụ AC Boost
với cả LGBM nó chỉ phù hợp khi các bạn
có rất nhiều dữ liệu mà thôi. Còn các
bạn có ít dữ liệu các bạn nên dùng Sơn.
Đấy
nói tiếp về đây nhá. Thế các bạn tưởng
tượng này. Bây giờ nói tiếp về cái việc
là cái việc khác biệt giữa academic
environment với cả industrial
environment. Như các bạn tưởng tượng này
thế bây giờ khi mà các bạn đi làm rồi ấy
thì cái công việc của các bạn ấy nó
không chỉ dừng ở cái việc là cái mô hình
của bạn nó có cái dự đoán chính xác đúng
không? D chính xác thì vẫn là các bạn
đang tự dùng với nhau, các bạn đang ngồi
trong phòng của công ty, các bạn đang tự
chạy trên máy của bạn thôi đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà bây giờ ấy các bạn muốn
kiếm được tiền cái sản phẩm này thì các
bạn phải triển khai được cho khách họ
dùng đúng không? Các bạn phải triển khai
được cái mô hình AI này cho khách họ
dùng.
Khi mà nói về triển khai mô hình cho
người khác dùng ấy thì nó có một vài
kiểu khác nhau. Cái kiểu phổ biến nhất,
cái kiểu mà dễ nhất để các bạn có thể
triển khai một cái ứng dụng B2, một cái
app cho người khác là các bạn sẽ triển
khai theo kiểu theo kiểu gì các bạn nhỉ?
Các bạn là một trang web là một cái ứng
dụng các bạn muốn triển khai cho người
khác dùng. Cách dễ nhất, cách phổ bi
nhất là người ta sẽ triển khai theo kiểu
gì các bạn?
Theo kiểu gì?
Đúng rồi, server client đúng không?
server tức là các bạn sẽ có thể thuê một
cái server của một ông lớn ở đây. Ví dụ
các bạn thuê server của Amazon đúng
không? Các bạn có AWS đúng không? Các
bạn thuê Microsoft Azure hoặc các bạn
thuê Google Cloud chẳng hạn đúng không?
Các bạn sẽ thuê một cái server của một
ông lớn sau các bạn sẽ chạy cái mô hình
bạn trên cái server đấy đúng không? Chạy
tất nhiên các bạn sẽ phải viết API cho
nó đúng không? Các bạn dùng viết API cho
nó và các bạn sẽ chạy về server các bạn
sẽ chạy mô hình bạn trên cái server đó
đúng không? Nó sẽ có một cái public IP
address. Đấy là phía server phía người
dùng. Ví dụ các bạn xem một cái ứng dụng
là chỉnh sửa ảnh bằng AI trên di động
chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì các bạn phải
viết một cái UI, một cái giao diện, một
cái app có cái user interface trên điện
thoại của bạn. Rồi các bạn thao tác trên
đấy. Rồi các bạn khi bạn thao tác xong
nó sẽ gửi cái request đấy đến cho cái
server. Server nó sẽ xử lý ảnh xong nó
sẽ gửi ngược lại đúng không? Thì lúc này
cái cái cái app trên máy của bạn ấy nó
chỉ nó chỉ phục vụ nhiệm vụ là gì? là nó
phục vụ cái giao tiếp giữa người giữa
giữa giữa chúng ta và cái server đấy
thôi. Giao tiếp gửi đi gửi lại các từ
như vậy được chưa? Hoặc là các bạn không
phải làm trên điện thoại mà làm trên app
à làm trên web nó cũng thế. Làm trên web
nó y chang như vậy không khác gì cả. Thế
cách này cách dễ nhất cách này cách dễ
nhất nhưng mà cái nhược điểm các bạn lúc
nào các bạn phải có các bạn phải trả
tiền cho cái server đấy các bạn trả tiền
theo tính theo giờ tính theo ngày gì đấy
hoặc tính theo tháng được chưa? Và lúc
nào cũng phải có internet không có
internet không chạy được đúng không? Tại
vì không có internet thì sẽ không có
connection giữa server với client. app
sẽ không chạy được đúng không? Mất
internet là app đồ đồ thải ngay. Được
chưa? Cách thứ nhất. Cách thứ hai là gì?
Cách thứ hai người ta gọi là onfiz tức
là gì? On premise tức là tôi ví dụ tôi
sẽ trang bị một cái thiết bị biên. Tức
là một cái thiết bị biên là cái gì?
Thiết bị biên các bạn hiểu đơn giản nó
là những cái mini PC. Tức là nó cũng
giống như PC của chúng ta nhưng mà nó
rất là bé thôi. Rất là bé thôi. Ví dụ
như này. Ví dụ chúng ta có những con như
này này.
Đây những con ví dụ đây nó kiểu kiểu như
này. Tức là nó rất là bé thôi mà nó cũng
đủ hết mọi tính năng của cái PC bình
thường. Nó cũng có mainbot, nó cũng có
chip, nó cũng có GPU, nó cũng có VGA
đâu, nó cũng có ờ đây nó cũng có đủ cả
đủ cả dây rợ chỗ cắm các thứ luôn. Đây
các bạn nhìn này. Đúng không? Chỗ cắm
USB cũng có nhá, cắm nguồn à cắm cắ cắm
mạng cũng có nhá. Cắm HDMI cũng có nhá,
cắm nguồn cũng có, đủ cả chả thiếu cái
gì cả. Muốn ngắm cái gì cũng được. Đấy,
thế con mini PC nó sẽ đi cùng với thiết
bị nó thiết bị nhận rượu vào nó sẽ
truyền vào đây để nó xử lý nó trả ngược
về. Ví dụ các bạn có những cái camera
sàn thất giao thông ấy đúng không? Thì
camera lắp ngoài đường nó đi cùng những
con này, camera nó thu nhận hình ảnh,
hình ảnh truyền vào đây nó xử lý, chuyển
vào đây xong nó sẽ trả ngược lại cho
camera để nó sâu ra ngoài. Ví dụ như vậy
đúng không? Làm như này các bạn sẽ là
thiết bị xử lý đi cùng với thiết bị thu
hình luôn và các bạn sẽ không cần phải ờ
lo về cái việc đoạn đường truyền nữa tại
vì h đi cùng với nhau mà chúng nối thẳng
với nhau mà đúng không? Thế các bạn nhìn
này. Thế thì khi mà các bạn làm thực tế
như vậy ấ thì các bạn sẽ phải cân nhắc
rất nhiều về cái việc là khi mà tôi muốn
triển khai một cái mô hình thực tế như
vậy ấ thì những cái ưu tiên của tôi là
gì? Ưu tiên nào là ưu tiên cao nhất? Ưu
tiên nào là ưu tiên thấp hơn? Và tôi sao
tôi để tôi đã đáp ứng tôi đáp ứng được
những cái ưu tiên này ví dụ nhá. Thật ra
thì với những cái thuật toán với những
cái mô hình trong cái khóa này của chúng
ta ấy thì cái việc mà ừ các bạn không
phải cân nhắc quá nhiều về cái đoạn là
tốc độ hay là tái nguyên tính toán. Tại
vì thật ra như mình nói rồi là những cái
tán machining là những tán mà kích thước
nó rất là bé thôi. Nó rất là bé. Các bạn
nhìn là cái mô hình ví dụ mô hình to
nhất là mô hình random fres đi nó chỉ có
khoảng vài trăm vài nghìn tham số thôi
được không? Thế thế nhưng mà ví dụ khi
chúng ta học về deep learning ví dụ các
bạn học về khóa sau hoặc về deep
learning chẳng hạn các bạn sẽ thấy là
trong deep learning ấy cái mô hình nó
vài triệu tham số là chuyện bình thường
vài triệu vài chục triệu tham số là
chuyện bình thường thậm chí sau này các
bạn nói về những cái mô hình ngôn ngữ
lớn cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn nó toàn vài
tỷ thậm chí là vài chục tỷ tham số là
chuyện hết sức bình thường thế thì bây
giờ các bạn hiểu là bây giờ mô hình các
bạn nó mà lớn các bạn mà muốn chạy được
nó đúng không mình nói về chạy được đã
đúng không chưa nói chạy nhanh chạy được
đã thì phần cứng các bạn đi cùng nó phải
lớn theo phần cứng đi cùng mà lớn theo
thì có nghĩa là cái chi phí nó sẽ độ lên
đúng không? Thế việc các bạn tưởng tượng
này, thế về các bạn tưởng tượng nhá. Bây
giờ mình đang xây dựng một cái mô hình
nó có chức năng là ờ nhận diện biển số
xe đúng không? Mình muốn triển khai cho
cảnh cho cảnh sát giao thông để có thể
bắt xem là cái xe nào nó vi luật giao
thông. Ví dụ như vậy đúng không? Thế thì
bây giờ các bạn tưởng tượng bây giờ giả
sử mình đã xây dựng được một cái mô hình
X rồi, một cái mô hình nó hình nhận diện
được biển xen rất là tốt rồi. Được chưa?
Các bạn học về deep learning cho for
competition các bạn sẽ biết đó là bài
toán OC optical character recognition
bài toán nhận diện ký tự trên hình ảnh.
Đấy cái mô hình của mình độ chính sác nó
rất là cao nhưng mà nó gạt một nỗi là
gì? Là bây giờ nó muốn xử lý một một bức
ảnh đầu vào, một cái khung hình đầu vào
từ camera ấy nó phải tốn 0,5 giây. Nó
phải tốn 0,5 giây. Có nghĩa là gì? Có
nghĩa là mình mình ấy độ thất nó rất là
cao nhưng nếu chỉ trong thực tế thì nó
sẽ chỉ đạt được FPS là 2 thôi. Tức là
hai khung hình trên 1 giây đúng không?
Nhưng mà vấn đề ở đây là gì? Là mình
chuyển trong thực tế, chuyển sang trong
giao lông ấy nó phải chạy trong thời ă
thực. Chạy ăn thực có nghĩa là gì? Tức
là 1 giây tối thiểu nó phải xử lý được 2
năm cùng hình đúng không? 25 FPS đúng
không? Hoặc là bé nữa phải khoảng được
khoảng 20. Cái mô hình của mình nó rất
là chính xác. Cái mô hình của mình mà đi
chấm điểm trên trường đại học ấy thì sẽ
được 10 độ chính chí giá nó cao thế
nhưng mà bây giờ đây ch thực tế nó nặng
quá nó quá nặng so với cái tài nguyên đi
cùng tôi sẽ không bảo tôi xử lý nó trong
thựt được. Thì dù mình của chúng ta nó
có tốt đến mấy tôi cũng không triển khai
được. Đ không tại vì là nó chạy chậm
quá, nó tốn nhiều tài nguyên quá đúng
không? Nó không đảm bảo yếu tố trong
thân ân thực đúng ch không đây là những
yếu tố mà những thứ liên quan đến deep
learning nói chung hay là những cái môi
ngôn ng lớn nói riêng người ta sẽ phải
quan tâm rất là nhiều đúng không? Làm
sao để tôi có thể với cái tài với cái
thiết bị đấy tôi vẫn có thể chạy mô hình
của tôi được. Nó phải đảm bảo cái độ
chính xác trong khi nó đảm bảo về những
cái yêu cầu liên quan đến tốc độ như là
tài nguyên tính toán đúng không? Các bạn
cứ tưởng tượng này. Bây giờ mô hình của
các bạn cũng làm tốt, mô hình của đối
thủ nó cũng làm tốt nhưng mà mô hình của
đối thủ nó nhỏ hơn gấp đôi mô hình của
bạn nó chạy trên thiết bị nó nhỏ hơn rẻ
hơn thiết bị của bạn khoảng 50 đô. Thì
bây các bạn thấy là tự nhiên bây giờ họ
sẽ có cái lợi thế mà cạnh tranh giá đúng
không? Hai ông chính sách như nhau nhưng
mà ông kia thậm chí là ông kia có thể
tồi hơn tồi hơn chúng ta một chút cũng
được nhưng mà họ rẻ hơn chúng ta gấp đôi
thì tách nhiên là khách hàng họ sẽ mua
của ông kia chứ đâu họ không có mua
chúng ta đâu đúng không? Thì những cái
yếu tố mà liên quan đến tốc độ, liên
quan đến tài nguyên nó sẽ ảnh hưởng trực
tiếp đến cái giá thành để các bạn có thể
deploy cái sẩm máy trong thực tế. Được
chưa? Kể cả chạy lên server cũng thế
thôi. Các bạn chạy một cái mô hình mà nó
nặng chẳng hạn các bạn sẽ phải thuê
server lớn server nó có c những những
cái con car đồ họa nó xịn đúng không?
Còn các bạn có cái mô hình nó nhỏ nhẹ
các bạn chạy lên server nó bé hơn đúng
không? Thì tất cả những cái này nó đều
liên quan đến cost, liên quan đến chi
phí vận hành và triển khai mô hình. Thì
là cái thứ các bạn sẽ phải quan tâm.
Thậm chí thậm chí ở ngay công ty mình
bây giờ ấy bọn mình trong tất cả những
bọn mình test ấy thì cái liên quan đến
magic là cái bọn mình test cuối cùng và
mình sẽ test về tốc độ về tài nguyên
tính toán trước. Hai ông này mà đảm bảo
rồi thì mình test về performance tại vì
là sẽ chả có ý nghĩa gì khi mình có một
cái mình cái magic nó rất là đẹp nhưng
mà nó không chạy được trong thực tế thì
nó nặng quá đúng không?
Cái này như mình nói rồi, ngay trong lớp
hiện tại chúng ta các bạn sẽ ít cần phải
quan tâm tại vì như mình nói cái mô hình
machining chạy rất là nhanh. Cái mô hình
machine các bạn không có GPU các bạn
chạy rất là nhanh nhưng mà deep link nó
sẽ không phải như vậy. Được chưa? Mà
thật ra thì bây giờ hầu hết các cái ứng
dụng fancy, cái ứng dụng thú vị ngành
của AI ấy chúng nó đều là những sản phẩm
trực tiếp của LM hoặc là của deep
learning tức là của những cái mạng
neuron ấy. Chứ còn những cái mô hình về
machining thì thường các bạn chỉ những
bạn nào các bạn theo khoảng dat các bạn
sẽ hay gặp nhiều thôi. Được chưa? Đúng
rồi. Chắc
bao giờ cũng thế thôi. Luật bất thanh
văn là gì? Các bạn muốn mô hình nhanh
hơn, mô hình nhỏ hơn, nhẹ hơn chạy tốn
ít tài nguyên hơn thì chắc chắn các bạn
sẽ phải sacrifice, các bạn sẽ phải hy
sinh về cái độ chính xác. Đây là điều
hiển nhiên bao giờ cũng thế. Được chưa?
Đây là cái thứ mà các bạn sẽ không bao
giờ phải quan tâm khi bạn đi học. Nhưng
mà đi làm đây là tôi rất là quan trọng.
Trong tin của mình bọ đã bọn mình đã
từng có những cái cuộc discussion nó rất
là căng thẳng chỉ về cái việc là
team AI của mình thì muốn là được dùng
thoải mái hơn về phần về phần cứng.
Nhưng mà cái team gọi là team cái team
về về product ấy thì họ lại muốn là giảm
cái chi phí đi. Giảm chi phí đi tức là
bắt dùng con bé đi. Đây các bạn nhìn
nhá. Ví dụ cái họson này.
Họ Chesson này
họ có rất nhiều mô hình. Đây các bạn
nhìn có rất nhiều mô hình đúng không? Từ
trái qua phải cái ông cái ông càng bên
trái nó càng nhỏ càng nhẹ càng rẻ nhưng
mà tài nguyên nó ít. Các ông sang bên
phải càng ngày nó càng to nó càng khỏe
hơn nó càng nhiều hơn. Đấy thì nó lại
tốn nhiều tài nguyên hơn kiểu kiểu như
vậy. Đấy
đúng không? Cái việc cạnh tranh về sau
này các bạn làm làm product ấy đúng
không? Cạnh tranh về độ chính xác nó
không phải cái yếu tố quan trọng nhất
đâu. Cạnh tranh về giá cả đúng không? Và
nhiều khi là cái việc là các bạn trình
bày các bạn visualiz nó như nào nó quan
trọng hơn cả cái việc là performance.
Tại vì sao? Các bạn tưởng tượng là sau
này ấ các bạn đi các bạn làm việc các
bạn trình bày với sếp hoặc các bạn trình
bày với đối tác ấy các bạn bảo là mô
hình của tôi tôi dành ra 1 tháng trời
tôi tăng được 1 2% accuracy họ cũng chả
quan tâm mấy đâu. Họ quan tâm là gì? là
tôi chạy hết bao nhiêu tiền tôi chạy tôi
cần thiết bị hết bao nhiêu tiền tôi chạy
được cái mù của ông đúng không đấy là
cái quan rất là quan trọng
đấy luôn có những thứ các bạn phải đánh
đổi đúng không thường speed với memory
này đi cùng nhau đúng không tăng speed
đúng không thường là tăng speed là các
bạn sẽ phải thu nhỏ mô hình đi thu nhỏ
mô hình đi thì các bạn sẽ tốn ít tài
nguyên hơn thường hai ông này bao giờ nó
đi cùng với nhau được chưa
này các bạn học về deing các bạn sẽ học
về những cái kỹ thuật nó giúp làm sao
các bạn có để thu nhỏ các bạn có thể nén
kích thức của mô hình. Ví dụ mình nói
qua một chút có một kỹ thuật rất là phổ
biến tronging.
Nó áp dụng nó áp dụng rất là phổ biến
trong đing và trong cả các cái môn ngôn
ngữ lớn sau triển khai các bạn chạy quá
trình influence, quá trình suy luận các
cái môn ngôn ngữ lớn ấy là kiểu gì người
ta cũng dùng. Đó là kỹ thuật người ta
gọi là kỹ thuật gọi là lượng tử hóa.
Lượng tử hóa hay là tiếng Anh người ta
gọi là model quantization, lượng tử hóa
mô hình. Thế nào lượng tử hóa mô hình?
Các bạn tưởng tượng đây nhá. Một cái mô
hình của chúng ta kể cả những cái mô
hình trong khóa này chúng ta học những
cái mô hình linear reaction support
vector machinerum for đúng không? Về v
mặt bản chất nó có rất nhiều những cái
tham số ở bên trong. Tham số là cái gì?
Ví dụ như là mô hình linear reaction
đúng không? Thì đây ví dụ mô hình linear
reaction thì các bạn
đây có phải nhá lin có vẻ là y bằng w1x1
cộng với w2x2 cộng với w3x3 đúng không?
Cộng v đúng chưa? Thì tham số nó chừ gì?
Thì the những cái giá trị W1 W2 này đúng
không?
Thật ra cái này phải gọi là ờ cái này
gọi là trọng số nhưng mà thôi mình gọi
là tham số cũng được gọi là parameter
được chưa? Này nó là parameter thì thông
thường ấy còn x1 x2 x3 là input đầu vào
đúng không? Input đầu vào nó thay đổi
thì nó sẽ thay đổi kết quả thôi. W1 W2
W3 nó là tham số số đồ vào nó sẽ cần
phải được nó sẽ ví dụ nó thường nó sẽ là
những cái được lưu chữ là trong dạng là
F F FP32
floating point 32 tức là gì? Tức là để
tôi lưu trữ được một cái tham số này,
tôi sẽ cần một cái thanh nghị. Tôi sẽ
cần sử dụng 32 bit. 32 bit thì bằng mấy
b các bạn nhỉ?
32 bit thì bằng mấy mấy b? 4 by đúng
không? Tại vì là cứ 8 bit là 1 B mà nó
các bạn học ID các bạn biết rồi đúng
không? C 8 bit này đúng không? 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 c 8 bit thành một b đúng không?
Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ tức là gì? Tôi muốn
biểu diễn ông W1, W2, W3, WN gì đấy thì
mỗi ông tôi sẽ cần phải dùng 32 bit hay
là 43 để tôi biểu diễn đúng không? 3 bit
thì nó tốn tài nguyên đúng không? Nó tốn
tài nguyên. biểu diễn nó tốn thành
nguyên chạy nó lâu thì bây giờ sẽ thì
tôi sẽ thu nhỏ đi. Tôi sẽ không để từ 3
bit nữa, tôi sẽ để là 16 bit thôi. Tôi
có FP 16 được chưa? FP32 người ta gọi là
single precision.
Sing đơn precision
thậm chí nó còn có FP64
SP
FP64 người ta gọi là double precision
còn FP32 người ta gọi là single
precision được chưa FP16 người ta gọi là
have
là một nửa đấy precision được chưa nó có
sau các bạn học về các bạn sẽ biết là có
những cái mô hình nó sẽ là mic giữa FP32
và F16 tức là nó phải lưu chữ tức là có
những chỗ là được lưu chữ bằng 16 nhưng
mà có chỗ phải lưu bằng 32. Thì cái kiểu
thì cái kiểu mic như vậy ấ thì người ta
sẽ gọi là mix
precision
đúng không? Tinh L với cả Hích nhau
thành mix
là giảm độ chính xác bao giờ cũng thế
thôi. Giảm tài nguyên mô hình nhỏ hơn,
nhẹ hơn chạ ít tài nguyên hơn thì đội
chính xác sẽ bị ảnh hưởng. Thế thôi được
chưa? Tiếp muốn giảm nữa, lượng tử hóa
nữa tôi sẽ đưa về ra là in8.
Mấy hôm kia là súng số thực 32 bit 16
bit tôi sẽ đưa về in8.
Thậm chí bây giờ là chúng ta còn đưa về
in4.
Đ ta đưa về tiếp là in 4.
Thậm chí có cả in 2
và thậm chí có cả in1.
Đấy đây gọi là lượng tử hóa đúng không?
Lượng tử hóa các bạn sẽ
dùng ít tài nguyên để các bạn lưu trước
các cái giá trị tham số hơn.
Tất nhiên mô hình nó sẽ bị giảm độ chính
xác. Đây là điều không tránh khỏi. Mà
thông thường ấy khi mà các bạn vẫn còn
dùng những cái định dạng phổ biến này
F16 mic này ấ thì hoặc là in8 ấy thì cái
độ giảm khí giác nó ít lắm. Mua hiển n
các bạn sẽ bị các bạn sẽ hy sinh một
chút xíu chính xác. Nhưng mà bù lại thì
m bạn nó nhỏ hơn nhẹ rất là nhiều. Các
bạn tiêu tốn ít tài nguyên hơn để các
bạn lưu trữ chúng. Được chưa?
Đây rất là quan trọng nhớ nhá. Mod
quantization
model
quantation
lượng từ hóa mô hình bạn nào sau này các
bạn đi sâu bạn đi học học tiếp lên về
đặc biệt là học về chắc chắn các bạn sẽ
gặp cái từ này một lần nữa nhiều lần nữa
chứ phải một lần nữa nhá
được chưa nó thường các bạn đi học trên
trường về machining các bạn dùng s
killer các bạn chỉ học đấy là mình nó dự
đoán là xong nhưng mà dự đoán xong nó
mới chỉ là một nửa câu chuyện thôi đúng
không? Tôi muốn bán được sản phẩm tôi
phải chỉ cho khách hàng người ta phải
dùng được chứ làm sao phải lúc nào người
ta cũng ngồi trước máy của chúng ta để
người ta xài được đúng không?
Rồi
có nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không
nhá? Thế thì ngoài ra nó còn có một cái
điểm nữa. Một cái điểm nữa là ngoài tất
cả những thứ mình vừa nói các bạn ấy thì
thông thường nhá, thông thường khi mà
chúng ta xây dựng, chúng ta huấn luyện
và chúng ta triển khai một cái mô hình
cho người khác họ dùng ấy thì thông
thường trong phần lớn trường hợp chúng
ta chỉ cần làm sao mô hình chúng ta nó
dự đoán càng chính xác thì càng tốt đúng
không? cái prediction của chúng ta nó
càng nó càng chính xác càng tốt. Thế
nhưng mà ví dụ đi, ví dụ các bạn xem một
cái mô hình để dư án giá nhà đi thì với
chúng ta là trong hết trường hợp chúng
ta chỉ làm sao cái mô hình chúng ta dư
án giá nhà nó càng sát về thực tế nó
càng tốt. Thế nhưng mà đôi khi có những
cái trường hợp người ta lại muốn là gì?
là không những là mô hình của tôi dự
đoán mà tôi còn muốn tôi quay ngược lại.
Tôi quay ngược lại để tôi giải thích xem
là vì sao mô hình của tôi nó lại nó lại
nó lại dự đoán như thế hoặc là cái yếu
tố nào nó ảnh hưởng lớn đến cái dự án
đầu da. Ví dụ như này, ví dụ như là bây
giờ tôi muốn quay ngượ lại tôi thấy là
trong các cái yếu tố liên quan đến diện
tích số tầng vị trí sổ đỏ của căn nhà
ấy, cái yếu tố nào là yếu tố nó ảnh
hưởng lớn nhất đến cái giá của căn nhà?
À tôi muốn có cái này tôi giải thích tôi
giải thích xem là cái vị trí ở đâu,
những cái vị trí đâu ví dụ như là Hà Nội
Hồ Chí Minh nó ảnh hưởng lớn nhất đến
giá nhà đúng không? Thì nếu mà tôi muốn
quay ngược lại tôi giải thích như này ấy
thì tôi phải chọn những cái mô hình có
khả năng giải thích hay tiếng Anh là
interpretability nó cao. Mô hình nào là
những mô hình có khả năng giải thích
cao? Là những cái mô hình mà thường nó
là mô hình đơn giản. Ví dụ như linear
reaction,
Kist là những cái mô hình mà các bạn có
thể quay ngợi các bạn giải thích nó rất
là đơn giản đúng không? Ví dụ như là
linear các bạn chuyển xem là trọng số
hôm nào có cái hệ số cái trị tuyệt đối
nó nó trị tu nó lớn thì nó sẽ ảnh hưởng
lớn đến cái target í đầu ra được chưa?
hoặc là mô hình c stable tôi chỉ quay
lại tôi xem là tôi bảo là tôi dự án như
vậy tại vì là những cái căn nhà gần cái
căn nhà này nhất căn nhà mà tương tự căn
nhà này nhất nó có chỉ số như thế đúng
không kiểu như vậy thế còn những cái mô
hình mà kiểu support machine chẳng hạn
hoặc là fres hoặc là đặc biệt sau này
chúng ta học về học về mạng neuron hoặc
trong deep learning ấy chúng về mạng
neuron đây mô hình nó cực kỳ khó giải
thích gần như là không thể giải thích
được các bạn chỉ biết là mô hình nó dự
tốt thôi còn vì sao thì chịu tại vì là
tại vì nó phức tạp thế thôi được chưa
Không với mình mình chưa từng bao giờ
gặp phải trường hợp như này tại vì mình
chả bao giờ chưa bao giờ cái những cái
buit của mình nó yêu cầu là phải quay
ngượ lại được như vậy. Thế nhưng mà có
những cái trường hợp các bạn sẽ cần phải
quan tâm đến cái yếu tố này đúng không?
Làm sao tôi có thể quay lại tôi giải
thích xem là mô hình của tôi nó tập
trung nó nhìn vào nó nhìn vào đâu, nhìn
vào cái feature nào. Được chưa?
Ok. Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây là cái ch off. Bao
giờ cũng vậy thôi. Độ chính xác càng cao
thì khả năng giải thích thì càng thấp.
Nó giống như kiểu này. Cái bài đơn giản
thì các bạn dễ giải thích. Bài càng phức
tạp thì càng khó giải thích đúng không?
Đ y trang như vậy. Đấy. Những cái mô
hình mà rất là đơn giản ví dụ như là
linear là logistication đúng không? Thì
độ chính xác nó thấp nhưng mà khả năng
giải thích thì cực kỳ cao. Càng mô hình
phức tạp hơn thì aquasi k tăng cao lên
nhưng mà tính xích nó thất rất là thấp.
Ví dụ như này cái tính giải thích của DC
nó sẽ cao hơn so với random fred tại vì
là nó chỉ là một cây thôi. Red nó nhiều
cây nhưng mà bù lại thì random fred
aquasin lại cao hơn. Được chưa? Đấy
các bạn nhìn nhá. Random fred chỉ là một
đại diện tiêu biểu của backing thôi chứ
nó không phải là backing đúng không? RF
nó là một cái một cái mô hình tiêu biểu
của backing chứ nó không phải là
backing. Thế nên là các bạn thấy nó ở
hai ô khác nhau. Được chưa? Còn deing
các bạn nhìn đây. Deep learning này đúng
không? Ling là những cái mô hình mà độ
nhá rất là cao nhưng mà gần như các bạn
chả thấy được cái gì cả tại vì nó có
nhiều neuron nó thành từng cái tầng từng
cái tầng các bạn sẽ không thể giải thích
được cụ thể là từng neuron nó làm cái gì
được chưa?
Rồi okhỉ
ra 5 phút các bạn nhá nghỉ ra 5 phút
nhá. Bạn nào các bạn có câu hỏi gì bạn
cứ hỏi nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi
nhá.
Nào cần gì các bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
khóa mình xong thì chắc là nghỉ tầm một
tuần cho mọi người
có thôi sức đó mình học tiếp khóa sau
nhá.
mình xong chứ là hai tuần nữa.
Người ta sẽ không người ta sẽ thường
người ta sẽ không nói là có bao nhiêu
model computeration mà sẽ nói là có bao
nhiêu bài toán. Bài toán này có nhiều
lắm. Image classification nhá. Object
detection object tracking object
segmentation nhiều nhiều lắm. Bài toán
thì nó rất là nhiều. Nó có khoảng 13 bài
toán phổ biến.
LM thì khóa LM và AG nhá. Mình sẽ có cái
khóa mình sau cái khóa này các cái khóa
mình nó sẽ có hai hướng. Một là bạn nào
các bạn thích làm việc với ảnh giống như
mình các bạn theo hướng compation. Hai
là bạn nào các bạn thích là sẽ LM agent
thì bạn theo hướng LM. Tất nhiên đều là
mình dạy thôi. Thế nhưng mà ý mình là nó
có hai hướng như thế. Mọi hướng là cái
hướng là cái hướng thường là thiên về
NLP nhiều hơn. Còn computation là cái
hướng làm việc về ảnh video nhá.
Hiện tại thời ngày nay thì mọi người có
vẻ mọi người xu hướng là mọi người ấy về
LM nhiều hơn
nhưng mình thích computer vision hơn.
Lúc dậy thì mình cũng thích dạy computer
vision hơn. mỗi cái đều có cái hay chỉ
có là nó là cảm nhận của cá nhân thôi.
Tại vì mình làm cho cái bảng C mình
nhiều quá rồi, kinh nghiệm của mình
trong này nó cũng nhiều hơn thì mình
thích làm hơn thôi.
Tiếp nhá, tiếp nhá.
Không các bạn ạ. Máy các bạn không có
chả sao tại vì mình đã chỉ nó có những
cái platform cho các bạn dùng free mà
nha các bạn. Máy các bạn có tốt không có
chả vấn đề gì.
Có chứ. Mình sẽ nói về cả về file tool
và cả ra nhá. Hai hướng tool với R. Đúng
rồi. Colab c chính xác. Cger nó do dùng
các bạn dùng 30 tiếng free mỗi tuần cơ.
Các bạn làm khoảng 5 s tài khoản là các
bạn dùng thoải mái rồi nhá. Tiếp này các
bạn này thì vừa rồi chúng ta vừa nói
việc là
những cái yếu tố mà phải cân nhắc khi
các bạn
muốn triển khai một cái mô hình trong
thực tế đúng không?
Magic magic nó chỉ một một phần thôi
đúng không? Speed này memory là một cái
phần rất là quan trọng đúng không? Thế
các bạn nhìn tiếp nhá.
Bây giờ ấy cái típ để chọn cái thu cái
mô hình cái thuật toán machine thì nó
rất là dễ thôi đúng không? Đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ bắt đầu bắn cái mô hình đơn giản.
Bắt đầu bắn cái mô hình đơn giản đúng
không? Ví dụ là bây giờ các bạn có một
cái bộ dữ liệu các bạn cứ ví dụ các bạn
có thể thử bắt đầu về linear reaction
hoặc là logistic hoặc là các bạn dùng
logistic reaction đúng không? Chọn mô
hình đơn giản thôi đúng không? Nhiều khi
ý cái mô hình đơn giản nhiều khi ý có
những cái bài toán mà người ta không yêu
cầu các bạn phải trải tế mô hình tốt
nhất mà người ta chỉ cần các bạn là gì
là có cái performance nó vượt qua một
cái ngưỡ đấy là xong. Tức là ví dụ tôi
tôi chỉ tôi không cần một cái mô hình dự
án siêu chính xác tôi chỉ một cái mô
hình dự án độ chính xác trên 70% là xong
đúng không? Thì nhiều khi các bạn dùng
mô hình đơn giản nó đã vượt qua cái mức
đấy rồi được chưa? Cái việc là vì sao
chúng ta lại nên bắt đầu một cái bài
toán bởi một cái mô hình đơn giản. Vì
thế này có rất nhiều lý do. Thứ nhất, mô
hình đơn giản nó sẽ dễ chạy, dễ huấn
luyện, dễ triển khai, chạy nhanh. Là cái
thứ nhất. Thứ hai nữa ấy là mình nên có
một cái mô hình đơn giản. Cái mô hình
này nó sẽ được coi như là một cái
baseline. Một cái baseline tiếng Việt
gọi là gì nhở?
một cái baseline tức là một cái mô hình
ở sau này các cái mô hình khác nó tham
chiếu nó so sánh đúng không? Các bạn
tưởng tượng này, bây giờ các bạn ngay
vào đầu phát ấy các bạn áp dụng một đống
các cái thuật toán, các bạn áp dụng một
đống cái kỹ thuật tiền xử lý phức tạp
rồi các bạn dùng mô hình này mô hình kia
cao siêu. Các bạn ngay vào đầu các bạn
chọn ngay như vậy ấ thì các bạn được một
cái mô hình có một cái performance gì
đấy. Nhưng mà các bạn cũng không biết là
những cái việc mà các bạn vừa làm ấy nó
có thực sự có ý nghĩa hay không. Các bạn
chọn một cái mô hình phức tạp, các bạn
tiền xử lý nhiều bước, các bạn làm cái
lọ cái chai, các bạn cũng không biết là
những cái bước đấy liệu có thực sự có ý
nghĩa không, đúng không? Thì muốn có ý
nghĩa ấy thì tôi phải có một cái gì đấy
để tôi có thể tôi đối chiếu tôi so sánh,
đúng không? Tôi phải có một cái mô hình
bas slide để tôi có thể tôi đối chiếu
tôi so sánh với cái mô hình đấy đúng
không? Chứ còn bây giờ giống như kiểu
các bạn tưởng tượng là bây giờ các bạn
bảo là một cái ông là ông đấy học giỏi,
ông đấy học giỏi là ông đấy phải học
giỏi với một cái ông nào khác đúng
không? Chứ còn ông đấy đứng đứng một
mình thì làm sao mà biết ông đấy học
giỏi ha rốt được đúng không? Hoặc là các
bạn bảo một cô gái sinh, sinh là sinh
với ai đúng không? Sinh là sinh với một
cô khác đúng không? Chứ còn đứng một
mình không thì làm sao biết thế nào là
sinh được đúng không? Thì đây nó cũng
như vậy. Khi chúng ta có trong machining
ấy chúng ta sẽ thường chúng ta nên bắt
đầu với m hình nó đơn giản chạy nhanh
chạy đ đơn giản đúng không? Dễ có một
cái kết quả sau này chúng ta sẽ sau này
chúng ta sẽ xửng cái mô hình khác tiền
kiểu khác các thứ khác nhau để chúng ta
có thể chúng ta so sánh với cách với cái
mô hình gốc ban đầu đấy. Được chưa? Cái
đấy là cái yếu tố đầu tiên đúng không?
Đấy và nhiều khi như mình nói rồi khi
mùi này nó tốt sẵn rồi các bạn chả cần
phải làm thêm cái gì nữa được chưa? Đây
cái thứ nhất. Sau đó thì bây giờ các bạn
sẽ sau khi các bạn đã xong với cái mô
hình đơn giản đấy rồi, các bạn xong cái
baseline rồi các bạn sẽ thử huấn luyện
cái bộ rượu đấy với
các bạn sẽ thử huấn luyện nhiều mô hình
khác với cùng bộ rượu đấy đúng không?
Các bạn có thể lệ mô hình khác các bạn
có thể thay tìm các cái kỹ thuật khác
nhau. Các bạn sẽ ra được cái shortlist
gồm những cái mô hình tốt nhất với những
tham số mặc định. Thì sau đó chúng ta sẽ
sử parameter turning.
cho những cái mô hình top ở trong cái
shist đấy. Ví dụ bạn có top 5, top 10
các bạn sẽ dùng green search hoặc là run
my search cho cái top đấy thôi. Cho cho
cái top đấy thôi. Được chưa? Nếu mà các
bạn có ít tổ hợp thôi, các bạn dùng
green search các bạn có nhiều các bạn
dùng cái randomiz search đúng không? Hai
hai option khác nhau. Nó c một vài cái
cái cái nữa cơ nhưng mà thôi chúng ta
cũng không cần phải đi quá sâu cái đấy.
Sau chúng ta sẽ xoay lại để xem là sau
khi tôi đã rồi thì cái thứ tự của các nó
có thay đổi không. Tôi sẽ chọn công là
tốt nhất. Thật ra các bạn phải chọn cả
mô hình tốt nhất và các bạn phải dựa vào
cái cái thời gian nó xử lý nữa. Nhiều
khi hai mô hình nhất nhì nó gần như nó
xêm xêm nhau nhưng mà một ông chạy nhanh
gấp ba lần ông kia thì các bạn sẽ ưu
tiên không chạy nhanh hơn đúng không?
Đấy.
Đấy là về cái việc là các bạn chọn cái
mô hình machining như thế nào được chưa?
Cái này thế ra cũng không có gì quá đặc
biệt đúng không? Các bạn học buổi này
rồi các bạn cũng thử hiểu cái này. Chúng
ta cũng từng làm điều đấy rồi đúng
không? Chúng ta cũng từng làm, chúng ta
cũng từng dùng lazy PRCK để chúng ta tìm
ra được cái top 5 đúng không? Do các bạn
cũng dùng green search rồi đúng không?
Nó chỉ là kết hợp của hai ông vào với
nhau thôi. Cái thời ngày xưa của mình
hồi mình còn làm data sence á thì hồi
đấy chưa có những cái th viện như kiểu
lấyp nên là hồi đấy bọn mình sẽ phải
chạy rất là nhiều lần và phải ngồi code
thủ công. Hồi đấy còn chưa có ai nó chưa
code hộ đâu. Phải ngồi tự code rất là
lâu nhưng bây giờ các bạn làm rất là
nhanh rồi. Được chưa?
Đó thế thôi đúng không? Nhưng các bạn
chú ý này, cái này ấ nó chỉ áp dụng được
cho các cái th toán machine truyền thống
này thôi. Nhưng cái thứ chúng ta học ở
khóa này thôi. Các bạn học lên khóa sau
rồi các bạn sẽ không còn áp dụng được
cái trò cái trò này đâu. Tại vì sao? Tại
vì ý như mình nói rồi những cái mô hình
trong dearning ấy toàn những cái mạng
neuron nó đến hàng triệu hàng chục triệu
tham số chạy nó rất là lâu. Một lần
chuyển nó có thể nó đến vài giờ hoặc là
vài ngày nên các bạn sẽ không có được
cái sự xa xỉ là các bạn hãy chạy hàng
chục mô hình. Rồi mỗi mô hình các bạn
lại dùng file tool để các bạn tìm xem
đâu là bộ x. Tốt nhất là các bạn sẽ
không có cái không có cái sự dư giải đâu
đúng không? Cái này nó chỉ áp dụng được
cho các cái mô hình chúng ta học lớp này
thôi. Còn học lớp sau chúng ta sẽ phải
dùng các cái kỹ thuật khác. Được chưa
nhá. Green search không ai người ta dùng
green search trong deep learning cả vì
thế ăn chạy một lần nó quá là lâu. Được
chưa?
Rồi. Ok. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không? Có
nào có câu hỏi gì không?
À cái t thực tế có hai cái bước là thứ
nhất là cái bước chuẩn bị dữ liệu. Chuẩn
bị dữ liệu dữ liệu ở đâu ra? Làm sạch
nó, đánh nhãn nó cáiứ nhất. Thứ hai là
cái đoạn triển khai mô hình là cái đoạn
lâu. Còn thật ra những cái bước ở giữa
tiền các bạn nhớ là hôm chúng ta nói về
cái pipeline có có mấy bước ấy đúng
không? Bước đầu với bước cuối là bước xử
lý dữ liệu à bước thu dữ liệu data
collection với bước cuối là model
deployment ấy. Hai bước đấy là hai bước
mà tốn ra nhất. Có những cái bước ở giữa
ra là Facebook nó làm hết mà ra hiểu ra
mình code một vài lần mình có sẵn code
rồi chạy dễ lắm chỉ có bước đầu bước
cuối thôi chuẩn bị dữ liệu, đánh nhãn dữ
liệu, làm sạch dữ liệu về bước cuối là
triển khai mô hình nó lâu thôi. Chuyển
khai mô hình nhiều khi là cùng cái mô
hình đấy các bạn triển khai trên thiết
bị của
của Google nó sẽ khác nhá. Trên thiết bị
của Nvidia nó sẽ khác nhá. Thiết bị của
Apple nó sẽ khác nhá. Nó khá là mất thời
gian
nhưng cái triển khai nó chỉ mất thời
gian khi mà các bạn làm dip learning
thôi. Machining thì nhẹ nhàng maching
rất là dễ.
Ok
mình sẽ không bao giờ mới file tun lượn
hết đâu vì chọn l những cái hyper
parameter nào mình thấy là nó quan trọng
nhất thôi. Còn mình không bao giờ mình
phải t được hết đâu đúng không? cũng
phải chọn lọc thôi.
Thông thường sách cái ler nó rất là dễ
tại vì là như mình nói rồi những cái
hyper parameter quan trọng quan trọng
nhất ấy sẽ đẩy lên trên cùng. Ví dụ các
bạn vào một cái toán bất kỳ các bạn chỉ
cần xem một vài cái tham số trên cùng
thôi là ok rồi.
Ví dụ như các bạn thấy là trong random
fr ấy nó chỉ có ngay là số cây với cả
cái c là hai cái quan trọng nhất thôi.
Mấy ông dưới nó ít quan trọng nhá.
Rồi
nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Các cái bước liên quan đến chỉ khai mô
hình ấy nó chỉ thực sự phức tạp khi nói
về mạng neuron, khi nói về deep
learning, khi nói về các ngôn ngữ lớn
còn triển khai cho maching rất là dễ các
bạn. Như các bạn chỉ sử dụng cái API để
chạy đến server. Thế là xong rồi.
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Ý em nào so sánh về magic? Khi có điểm
magri thì ông nào điểm tộ điểm cao hơn
thì tốt hơn thôi. Hai ông có điểm
precision chẳng hạn, ví dụ các bạn tập
trung vào precision đúng không? Thì ông
nào điểm cao hơn thì tốt hơn thôi, có
khó gì đâu. Đúng không? Thế bây giờ có
hai ông cùng một bài test đúng không?
Một ông được 9 điểm, một ông được 8
điểm. Thế hỏi ông nào tốt hơn? Tất nhiên
là ông chín điểm tốt hơn rồi đúng không?
Có cái gì đâu
đúng không? So sánh so sánh hai mô hình
dựa vào magic là cái dễ nhất trần đời
rồi. Làm gì có cái gì dễ hơn nữa đâu.
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Đúng không? Có có những cái trực quan mà
các bạn có dễ hiểu mà đúng không?
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Rồi tiếp theo chúng ta nói về một cái
nói về một cái kh một cái vấn đề nữa là
gì? Liên quan đến hôm nọ chúng ta nói
rồi ta có nói một lần rồi nói về
underfitting về fitting chúng ta biết
rồi đúng không? Underfitting là trường
hợp mà mô hình nó đơn giản quá trong khi
dữ liệu thì phức tạp.
Feitting ngược lại là mô hình nó quá
phức tạp so với dữ liệu. Chúng ta muốn
có cái optimal fitting là nó fit, tức là
độ phức tạp của dữ liệu, độ phức tạp của
mình là tương đương nhau. Nói thì là vậy
thôi nhưng mà để đạt được cái trạng thái
này không hề đơn giản một chút nào. Để
đạt được cái trạng thái là độ phức tạp
của dữ liệu với độ phức tạp mô hình
tương đương nhau là không dễ nà. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì thật ra ấy thật ra chúng ta
gần như chúng ta cũng chả có cái gì
chúng ta có thể dùng để chúng ta đo
lường được cái độ phức tạp của dữ liệu.
Nó khác với kiểu là Aquacy Vision Code
F1. Chúng ta sẽ có cái điểm là từ 0 đến
100 chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đúng không?
Nhưng mà độ phức tạp đúng không? Độ phức
tạp của mô hình với dữ liệu đâu? Model
complexity với cả data complexity làm gì
có gì để đ để đo đo lường đâu đúng
không? Chẳng có cái gì để đo lường độ
phức tạp cả. Đấy của của của dựa với của
mô hình cả đúng không? Nên tìm nó không
dễ một chút nào.
Thông thường ấy trong hai hiện tượng này
ấ cái hiện tượng mà các bạn sẽ hay gặp
hơn là fitting.
Fitting là cái thứ các bạn sẽ hay gặp
hơn. Còn under các bạn ít khi gặp lắm.
Mà nếu có gặp các bạn xử lý rất là dễ,
các bạn đẩy thành mô hình phức tạp hơn
là xong thôi. Nhưng mà oving rất là khó
để các bạn có thể cái viting này rất hay
xảy ra, rất khó tránh nó. Thế thì
để có thể ngăn chặn được cái hiện tượng
ting ấy thì nó có rất nhiều cách khác
nhau từ đơn giản đến phức tạp. Nhưng mà
trong đó có một họ các cái kỹ thuật rất
là phổ biến và người ta gọi chúng chung
với một cái tên gọi là regularization.
Regularization. Cái này ấ mình cũng
không biết tiếng Việt dịch là như nào
nhưng mà như có một lần mình đọc một cái
tài liệu người ta gọi là chính quy
mình mình biết nghĩa nó là gì nhưng mà
mình cũng không biết là tiếng Việt mình
có cái từ nào
để để để
thể hiện cái từ này. Nhưng mà region cái
ý nghĩa của request là gì? Các bạn tưởng
tượng nhá. Các bạn nhìn này. Ở đây mình
có ba cái hình được chưa? Ba cái hình
này dữ liệu thì giống nhau. Dữ liệu được
tự được đại diện bởi các cái hình ngôi
sao này. Được chưa? Các hình ngôi sao
này nó chính là cái rượu đồ vào của mình
đấy. Đúng chưa? Thì các bạn tưởng tượng
này, cái trường hợp đầu tiên, cái trường
hợp đầu tiên là cái trường hợp mà
trường hợp đầu tiên là cái trường hợp mà
tôi dùng một cái mô hình linear
regression đúng không? Mô hình nó quá là
đơn giản. Mô hình nó quá đơn giản nên là
nó đ nó đâu có fit đâu.
Mô hình nó không fit vào dữ liệu đúng
không? Trường hợp thứ trường hợp này đây
chính là trường hợp chúng ta gọi là
underfitting đấy. Dữ liệu phức tạp hơn
so với mô hình. Được chưa?
Trường hợp ở giữa là cái trường hợp mà
chúng ta tăng cái độ phức tạp của mô
hình đi đúng không? Ví dụ chúng ta tăng
mô hình độ phức tạp từ từ bậc 1 lên bậc
hai chẳng hạn đúng không? Thật ra với
cái hình này đây cũng không phải bậc hai
đúng không?
Thật ra cái hình này đây không phải là
bậc hai mà thôi chúng ta hãy coi như nó
là bậc hai đi. Được chưa?
Trong trường hợp này mình tăng cái độ
phức tạp của mô hình lên đúng không?
Tăng từ bậc 1 lên thành bậc hai chẳng
hạn thì các bạn thấy là rõ ràng là khi
mà tôi tăng cái độ phức tạp của mô hình
lên thì rõ ràng tính mô hình của tôi cụ
thể đây là cái đường này nó fit với rượu
hơn. Nó fit với rượu hơn đúng không? Tôi
tăng lên bậc hai nó phí rượu hơn đúng
không? Thế bây giờ tôi mới thấy là gì?
là à tôi mới tăng này bậc hai mới bậc
hai thôi mà nó đã fit với rượu như này
rồi đúng không gần như là chính xác rất
là tuyệt đối ca này đúng không thì bây
gi
phức tạp của mô hình lên tại vì sao mấy
bậc hai mà đã làm tốt này rồi thì chắc
hẳn bậc 10 bậc 100 nó phải làm tốt nữa
đúng không ví dụ cùng một bài toán nhá
đúng lúc đầu các bạn đưa cho một đứa lớp
1 làm làm rất là tồi cho một lớp 2 làm
nó tốt hơn. Tôi nghĩ là à lớp 2 làm thế
này rồi. Khi lớp 5 lớp 10 nó làm còn tốt
nữa đúng không? Tôi đưa cho cao hơn.
Được chưa?
Thì ví dụ đây đúng không? Bây giờ tôi
đẩy lên mô hình bậc 10 chẳng hạn nó như
này các bạn nhìn này. Về mặt bản chất ấy
nếu mà nếu mà so sánh về magic, so sánh
về số liệu mà nói ấy thì cái mô hình bậc
10 này
nó còn tốt hơn mô hình bậc hai. Tại vì
sao? Mô hình bậc hai bạn nhìn cái ông
cái điểm sai này đúng không? Nó còn dự
án nó còn hơi hơi tồi nhưng mà cái mô
hình bậc 10 này thì nó lại dự án rất là
tốt đúng không các bạn? Không gần như là
perfect luôn. Tất cả năm điểm đều
perfect luôn đúng không? Thì rõ ràng ấy
nếu mà bây giờ ấy tôi chỉ so sánh về số
về magic thôi ấy thì do là cái ông cuối
nó còn tốt hơn cái ông ở giữa được
không? Giống như kiểu là bây giờ
phân cùng một công việc cho hai ông làm
đúng không?
Cái ông đầu tiên là một ông lao công giá
rẻ, ông ấy làm được khoảng 90 điểm các
bạn. Tiếp theo các bạn thuê một cái ông
giáo sư ông ấy làm ông ấy được 91 điểm.
Thì rõ ràng nếu mà chỉ tính là về cái độ
xuất sắc của cái kết quả làm thôi ấy thì
cái ông giáo sư sẽ làm tốt hơn rất nhiều
so với ông Lao Công đúng không? Thế
nhưng mà
vấn đề ở đây là ở chỗ là gì? Thứ nhất ấy
là dùng cái ông giáo sư ấy thì chi phí
nó sẽ lớn hơn đúng không? chi phí nó sẽ
lớn hơn. Và thứ hai nữa là cái thứ hai
nữa là ví dụ trong trường hợp cái mô
hình này ấ thì khi mà tôi dùng cái mô
hình nó quá là phức tạp ấy thì trong
tương lai nếu có những cái rượu mới rất
dễ là cái mô hình tôi nó sẽ làm sai đúng
không? Ví dụ cái hình ở giữa này trong
tương lai mình có một cái đi hiểm nó ở
đây chẳng hạn là cái ở chỗ chuột mình
này đúng không? Thì mô hình nó dự nó vẫn
tương đối chính xác nó vẫn đi qua rất là
tốt này được không? Thế nhưng mà trong
tương lai nếu mà tôi với cái mô hình
cuối cùng này đúng không? Cái điểm nó ở
đây thì đấy là cái mô hình của tôi nó đi
qua chả liên quan gì luôn. Nó chả liên
quan gì
được chưa? Tức là gì? Tức là cái mà tôi
nhắm đến không phải là ông chỉ tốt trên
cái bộ training hoặc là cái bộ variation
mà ông còn phải tốt trên cái bộ test sau
này nữa. Tức là sau này tôi đem ông chỉ
cho trong thực tế tôi phải tốt chứ còn
bây giờ lúc học tôi điểm cao lúc thi đ
thấp thì chả có ý nghĩa gì cả đúng
không? Thế thì có nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa
là bây giờ tôi phải có cách nào đấy là
gì? Thứ nhất là khi mà tôi huấn luyện mô
hình, mục tiêu của tôi tất nhiên mục
tiêu tối thượng của tôi là gì? Là làm
sao để chịu mô hình của tôi dự là nó
càng chính xác thì càng tốt. Tức là cái
dự án cù mô hình phải càng gần với thực
tế thì càng tốt đúng không? Thì đấy vẫn
là luôn là cái tiêu chí lớn nhất của tôi
rồi. Thế nhưng mà ngoài ra tôi còn một
cái tiêu chí nữa tôi mới phải đảm bảo là
gì? Tôi làm sao tôi cố gắng tôi giữ cái
mô hình tôi nó càng đơn giản thì càng
tốt. Tại vì mô hình nó càng đơn giản thì
nó sẽ càng dễ tránh được overfitting
đúng không? Có hai mục tiêu. Một là mô
hình dự đoán càng chính xác thì càng tốt
và hai là mô hình nó càng đơn giản thì
càng tốt. Ví dụ ở đây trong nh mô hình
đơn giản đây ví dụ đây giả sử đây là hàm
bậc nó phải nó phải phức tác hơn bậc 4
mà tôi mình sẽ coi như đây là hàm bậc 4
đi đúng không? Hàm bậc 4 này đúng không?
H bậc 4 thì ví dụ nó là ax mũ 4 + bx mũ
3 + cx bình + x + e đúng không? Đúng
không? Đấy. Thế bây giờ ý tưởng của tôi
là gì?
Tức là khi ví dụ tôi dùng cái mô hình
polynomial reaction mô hình bậc à mô
hình đa thức đi đúng không? Tôi để cho
bậc 10 bậc 100 nhưng mà tôi sẽ một cố
gắng tôi một hết mô hình là gì? Là hãy
cố gắng dùng cái bậc nào mà thấp nhất có
thể đúng không? Hãy cố gắng dùng cái bậc
nào mà thấp nhất có thể tôi giải quyết
đúng không? Nếu dùng được bậc 10 thì dễ
rồi nếu mà dùng được bậc 8 bậc 4 bậc 2
chẳng hạn mà giải quyết được thì càng
tốt đúng không? Thì tôi sẽ phải có một
cái cơ chế tôi khuyến khích cái mô hình
nó giảm độ phức tạp đúng không? Ví dụ
mua hình bậc 4 mà muốn giảm độ phức tạp
thì có nghĩa là những cái ví dụ tôi có
thể tôi sau đó rơi về bậc hai. Muốn rơi
về bậc hai thì cái hệ số của bậc 4 b3 nó
phải nó phải bằng 0 đúng không? Cái
trường hợp mà mô hình bậc cao mà những
cái hệ số của những cái bậc cao nhất này
nó bằng 0 nó bị rơi về cái bậc thấp hơn
ấy trong toán người ta gọi đây là chiều
này người ta gọi là bị làm sao nhỉ? Mô
hình nó bị làm sao các bạn? Mô hình nó
từ bậc cao đúng không? Cái hàm nó từ bậc
cao thành bậc thấp này người ta gọi là
mô hình là tán là cái hàm nó bị làm sao?
Đúng rồi. Bị suy biến. bị suy biến đúng
không? Chúng ta muốn là kết hợp giữa
việc là mô hình nó phải dự án tốt và
giảm đội phức tạp của mô hình. Thế nhưng
mà ấy hai cái việc này thật ra mà nói ấ
hai việc này thật ra mà nói đây là hai
việc đối nghịch với nhau. Cái việc mà
các bạn muốn nó mô hình dự đoán càng
chính xác thì càng tốt và mô hình nó
càng đơn giản thì càng tốt. Thật ra
chúng nó đối nghịch nhau. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì muốn mô hình dự đoán chính xác
thì chúng ta thường là cái mô hình nó
phải phức tạp. Mô hình nó phải nó phải
giỏi lên. nó phải nó phải giỏi nó phải
phức tạp nó mới làm được chứ đúng không?
V cái bài cho ông thạc sĩ làm muốn tốt
hơn là cho ông tiến sĩ tốt hơn ông giáo
sư đúng không? Tức là mô hình nó phải
muốn mô hình dự án tốt thì thông thường
là mô hình nó phải phức tạp lên.
Thế nhưng mà nếu tôi muốn cái mô hình
của tôi nó
đơn giản nó tránh bị hitting ý thì tôi
lại phải giảm độ phức tạp của mô hình.
Tức là hai cái thứ nó nó contradict nó
mâu thuẫn với nhau đúng không? Thế nên
là bây giờ ấy để tôi có thể tôi tôi tôi
mô tôi tôi mô hình hóa cái bài toán của
tôi thì bây giờ tôi sẽ sử dụng một cái
hàm gọi là hàm
một cái gọi là cost function.
C function ở đây tôi sẽ bao gồm hai
thành phần nhá. Đây là hai cái cách khác
nhau. Nói đầu tiên cách đấy là e1 người
ta gọi là regation. Tí mình sẽ thấy các
bạn nghĩa là gì các bạn nhá. A1 region
thì nó sẽ có hai thành phần. Thành phần
đầu tiên nó chính là cái hàm los. Các
bạn nhìn cái i này nó chính là cái giá
trị thực tế. Còn cái x y wj này nó chia
là cái giá trị dự đoán được chưa? Nó chư
là x nhân với w đấy. Nó chưa dự đoán
đúng không? Thực tế trừ dữ đán bình
phương chư là min square thôi. Chả có gì
đặc biệt cả đúng không? Thành phần thứ
hai chính là cái thành phần mà mình sẽ
là gì? Ví dụ cái ch1 này nó sẽ gì? Nó
bằng cộng với lamda. Lamda này nó là cái
giá nó là cái giá trị nó thể hiện cái
mức độ tương quan giữa hai thành phần
này ông nào quan trọng hơn. Được chưa?
Nếu nó bằng 1 thì ông quan trọng như
nhau đúng không? Lớn hơn 1 thì ông thứ
hai quan trọng hơn. Nhỏ hơn 1 ông đầu
tiên quan trọng hơn. Tổng sigma của J
chạy từ 0 đến m. M là cái gì? M là số
lượng tham số của mô hình. Thế còn I là
cái gì? Y là số lượng sample của dữ
liệu. Các bạn vậy các bạn có 100 sample
thì n = 100. Các bạn có
10 feature thì m sẽ bằng 10 đúng không?
M là số lượng cột, n là số lượng hàng.
Các bạn hiểu đơn giản như vậy. Được
chưa? Thì tôi sẽ có nhân thứ hai cộng
lamda tổng sigma của jạ từ t m wj này.
Đây chia bậc 1. Thế nên đây ta gọi là
one realization.
Còn L2 nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi thành phần
là đây sẽ là bình phương thôi. Được
chưa? Còn cái thành phần L giống hiệt
nhau được chưa? Thì các bạn tưởng tượng
này đúng không? Đây chính là hai thứ nó
đại diện cho hai thứ nó đối nghịch nhau.
Muốn dự đoán chính xác thì môi hình phải
phức tạp đúng không? Thì mô hình phức
tạp thì dự nó sẽ chính xác thì cái loss
nó sẽ bé. Nhưng mà khi lost bé như vậy
tham số nó mua hình phức tạp thì tham
tham số nó sẽ lớn. Tham số lớn thì W nó
cũng sẽ tăng lên. W nó cũng sẽ tăng lên
đúng không? Nó cũng sẽ tăng lên thì ờ m
hình nó sẽ vứt nó sẽ phức tạp hơn. thì t
nó sẽ làm cho t phần thứ hai gọi là re
th nó tăng lên còn ngược lại tôi muốn
giảm độ phức tạp của mình tôi phải cho
down nó bé đi. Bé đi thì nó sẽ khiến cho
cái phần đầu tiên lại lớn lên được chưa?
Thế thế nên là tôi phải tôi phải tìm
được cái điểm cân bằng giữa giữa hai ông
này đúng không? Ông này bé thì ông kia
sẽ lớn hơn người lại. Tôi phải tìm được
cái điểm cân bằng sao tổng cho hai ông
nó nó nhỏ nhất. Cái l này thường nó trị
rất là bé nó chỉ bằng 0,01 thôi. Tại vì
sao 0,01 nghĩa là gì? Tức là cái thành
phần l ấy nó vẫn lớn hơn thành phần
regularization.
Vì sao mang lại bé? Tại vì thật ra ấy
cái mục tiêu tối thượng của tôi khi tôi
huấn luyện mô hình vẫn là gì? Vẫn là mô
hình nó phải chính xác đúng không? Các
bạn có công nhận không? Các bạn xem cái
mô hình dự án giá nhà thì mua tối hiệu
của tôi không phải là mô hình đơn giản.
M tối hiệu của tôi là gì? Là mô hình nó
dự án tốt. Thế nên là suy cho cùng thì
phải lot vẫn có nhậm hơn. Nhưng mà tôi
phải có thêm thành phần regation này để
làm sao để tôi có thể tôi kiềm chế cái
độ phức tạp của mô hình. Tránh cho việc
mô hình nó nó super complex nó nó siêu
phức tạp đúng không? Đấy cái hình ở đây
các bạn nhìn hai minh họa này nhá. Những
cái hình elip đồng tâm này chính là cái
đường của loss. Còn cái phần hình tho
hình tròn này nó chính là cái đường của
cái region này. Thì cái điểm
thì cái điểm mà chúng ta cái điểm tối ưu
là cái điểm mà chúng nó cắt nhau đúng
không? Cắt nhau như này. L1 và L2. L1
các bạn chú ý nhá. Hai ông này ấ nó sẽ
có cái tính chất nó khác nhau. Các bạn
nhìn kỹ này. Giả sử nhá. Giả sử ấy, mô
hình của mình nó chỉ có hai tham số thôi
là W1 với W2 nhá. Các bạn nhìn này, cái
điểm cái nghiệm ấy cái nơi giao nhau ấy
nó sẽ cái nơi cái điểm màu đen này ấy nó
là điểm nằm trên trục W2.
Cái điểm này mà nằm trên W2 có nghĩa là
W1 nó làm sao các bạn?
Có nghĩa là sao?
Cái điểm giao nhau giữa cái chỗ L với cả
cái chỗ R này lên 1 bằng 0. Đúng. Nào,
mô hình y = w1x1 cộng w2x2 c w0. W1 = 0
có nghĩa là gì?
W 0 có nghĩa là gì?
Chưa phải mô hình sự biến. W1 = 0 có
nghĩa là x1 chẳng còn đóng vai trò gì
nữa. Có đúng không?
W1 = 0 có nghĩa là X1 nó chẳng còn đóng
file trò gì nữa.
Các bạn cã tưởng tượng bây giờ một cái
bộ rượu có 10 feature các bạn cho áp
dụng cái L1 này thì nó sẽ có cái xu
hướng là gì? Nó sẽ có xu hướng là nó sẽ
ép cho tức là cả hai ông này E1 và E2 ấy
nó đều có mục đích là gì? Là làm giảm độ
phức tạp của mô hình. Nhưng mà cái hướng
tự cận nó sẽ khác nhau. Ông L1 là hướng
gì? Là hướng gọi là chọn lọc đặc trưng.
Tức là gì? Tức là nó sẽ ép cho
hệ số của một vài những cái feature về
0. Mà khi nó về không rồi cái ông đấy nó
chẳng còn tác dụng gì nữa đúng không?
Chỉ có những ông còn lại thôi. Được
chưa? Đấy là cách mà E1 nó làm. Cách L2
nó làm là cái gì? Cách L2 nó làm là nó
sẽ các bạn nhìn này. Cái cái nghiệm của
E2 nó là cái nơi mà nó không nằm trên
trục này mà nó cũng chả nằm trên trục
kia. Có nghĩa là gì? Tức là E L2 nó có
xu hướng là gì? sẽ làm giảm đối phức tạp
theo cách là nó sẽ ép cho hệ số của tất
cả các cái feature đều bé đi nhưng mà
không ông nào bằng 0 hẳn đúng không? Tất
cả đều bị ép bé đi nhưng mà không có ông
nào bằng 0 hẳn. Ông W1 cũng bé đi, ông
W2 cũng bé đi nhưng mà không nào bằng 0
hẳn. Thế nên đang khai tác dụng đúng
không? Nếu chúng ta huấn luyện mô hình
mà chúng ta có quá nhiều feature và
chúng ta không chắc rằng tất cả chúng
đều quan trọng, chúng ta dùng L1. Còn
khi chúng ta đã có chúng ta có ít
feature, không phải chúng ta ít feature
mà chúng ta có feature nhưng mà chúng ta
chúng ta chúng ta chúng ta chỉ muốn là
giảm được phức tập của mô hình thôi.
Chúng ta muốn là các cái feature này vẫn
đều đóng góp trong đạn cuối. Chúng ta
không muốn loại bỏ hoàn toàn một cái
feature nào cả. Chúng ta sẽ dùng L2 được
chưa?
L1 và L2 nó còn cái tên khác. Cái này
vẫy cái lớp mình vừa mới hỏi xong mà chả
có bạn nào nhớ cả. L1 có một tên gọi
khác là
LO
L2 mà tên gọi khác là Rich
Ridge được chưa? RID LO với cả Rich. Thế
còn người ta có một kiểu nữa là ta kết
hợp cả L1 với L2
thì người ta gọi là elasticet.
Được chưa? L và elasticet.
Nhìn nhá
các bạn nhìn này. L ngoài cùng bên trái,
Rich là ở giữa, elastic là ngoài cùng
bên phải.
Khi các bạn tối ưu cost là bản thân bên
trong các bạn cũng đã tối ưu los rồi
đúng không? Khi các bạn tối ưu cost là
bản thân bên trong là tối ưu cost rồi.
Các bạn hiểu cái cost này khi các bạn
khi các bạn áp dụng requization thôi
nhưng mà không phải lúc nào người ta
cũng áp dụng. Có những mô hình là bản
thân nó nó sẽ không không có cái cái gì
để mà áp dụng cả đúng không? Cái rew này
mặt bản chất là gì? Là để tôi có thể tôi
làm giảm đố phức tạp của mô hình. Nhưng
mà không phải mô hình nào cũng có cái để
mà giảm. Có những mô hình các bạn không
giảm được. Ví dụ là gì? Ví dụ cây ne
stable không giảm được vì đây là mô hình
nó không có tham số đúng không? Cây ne
stable là mô hình không có tham số các
bạn sẽ không có cái gì để mà giảm cả
đúng không? Không cái gì giảm được. Hoặc
là có những cái mô hình người ta sẽ
thường người ta sẽ ít áp dụng. Ví dụ như
là ví dụ như là support machine. Các bạn
nhớ là cái cách khi mà tôi dùng support
machine ấy ý gì là tôi sẽ tạo ra cái
chiều mới đúng không? Để tôi đảm bảo là
gì? Ở cái chiều gốc ban đầu tôi không
phân không không phân chia được thì tôi
khi tôi lên cái chiều mới tôi sẽ phân
chia được đúng không? Bản chất khi người
ta dùng nó người ta muốn tăng độ phức
tạp của nó lên như thế bây giờ người ta
b ch đúng không? Tôi dùng sub vom để tôi
tăng độ phức tạp nên tôi lại áp dụng nó
lại giảm độ phức tạp đi thì hai cái việc
nó tránh ngược nhau đúng không? Không
phải lúc nào cũng dùng được đúng không?
Có chỗ dùng được có chỗ không. Được chưa
nhá? Nhớ nhá. Lasso này rich này và
elasticet đúng không? Nhìn cái nghiệm
của lo chưa? Nằm trên một trục. Có nghĩa
là đây là trường hợp các bạn chỉ có hai
tham số. Còn khi bạn có nhiều tham số
bạn khoảng 100 chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ có x
nó sẽ ép tham số của nó sẽ ép cho một
vài cái ông ít quan trọng thì tham số nó
sẽ về không đúng không? Có những cái ông
ông nào về không rồi thì coi như ông đây
chả có đóng góp cái gì cả.
Rồi ok.
Có nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Tiếp nhá.
Thì các bạn nhìn đây ví dụ đây đúng
không? Ví dụ đây nhá. Đây vẫn là về cái
bộ diabet này. Được chưa? Đây vẫn là về
cái bộ diabet. Thì các bạn nhìn thấy bên
trái là các bạn đang dùng lo. Bên phải
các bạn dùng reach nhá. L1, rich là được
chưa? Thì các bạn nhìn này, chúng ta có
tổng chúng ta có bảy feature à chúng có
tám feature đúng không? Thì các bạn nhìn
này, khi mà các bạn các bạn áp dụng lấy
ấy, các bạn có thấy là trong số tám
feature này có một cái feature mà cụ thể
là cái skin thchnit ấy đúng không? Mình
ở đây mình in ra các cái hệ số của nó
đúng không các bạn? Tưởng tượng là tá
feature nó sẽ giống kiểu là y = w1x1
cộng w2x2 cộng w3x3 vân cộng w8x8 cộng
w0 đúng không? Thì đây mình sẽ in ra các
cái hệ số từ w1 w8 thì các bạn thấy là
gì? Là cái hệ số của ông skinet này nó
bằng 0 đúng không? Đây chính là cái đặc
điểm của đấy đúng không? Nó sẽ cố ép hệ
số một hoặc một vài cái feature về 0.
Tất nhiên không phải lúc nào nó cũng ép
được. Có lúc có có lúc không. Thế nhưng
mà nhìn chung xù nó là nó sẽ ép. Khi về
không rồi coi như là các bạn mất đi một
feature rồi. Các bạn chỉ còn bảy feature
còn lại thôi. Được chưa? Còn bên phải là
rich rich và L2 với L2 thì nó sẽ có xu
nó sẽ ép cho tất cả điều bé nhưng mà chả
nào bé hẳn chả nào về không hẳn cả. Được
chưa? Thì thôi
rồi.
Rồi mai có câu hỏi gì không?
Thế nhá. Thế đang nói về
không nếu là em ăn béo thu ấ nếu mà cái
kết quả của cù nó vẫn sẽ khác nhau tức
là kết quả hai ông nó sẽ không giống y
trang nhau đấy nhưng mà xu hướng của mỗ
11 một khác ông he là xu hướng là giảm
độ phức tạp bằng cách là ép hẳn một vài
ông về 0 còn là ép ép đều đúng không kể
cả e nó không có ép được về 0 thì nó sẽ
ra kết quả nó sẽ khác chứ nó không giống
hoàn toàn với eo2 đâu nhá
Giống kiểu là hai người cùng tối ưu hóa
một cái ứng dụng nhưng mà một ông tối ưu
hóa về tốc độ, một ông tối ưu hóa về bộ
nhớ vậy đúng không? Hai ông đều là tối
ưu hóa nhưng mà mỗi ông một kiểu. Được
chưa?
Rồi. Thế ở đây ý nhân tiện cho chúng ta
đang nói về cái việc là áp dụng. Các bạn
chú ý nhá, cái kỹ thuật requir này là nó
cũng kỹ thuật rất là phổ biến và đặc
biệt sau này các bạn học về deep
learning nó cũng dùng rất là rộng rãi.
Sau deing chúng ta sẽ có rất nhiều cái
kỹ thuật dùng để người ta có thể ờ
regularize là tôi kiềm chế độ phức tạp
của mình. Với disning nó rất là quan
trọng. Tại vì sao? Tại vì bản thân những
cái mô hình tronging ấy là những cái mô
hình dựa trên mạng neuron là những cái
thứ mà nó rất là phức tạp, rất nhiều
tham số. không áp dụng reizion nó sẽ
khiến cho mô hình nó bị không kiểm soát
được sẽ khiến cho mô hình nó gần như nó
sẽ không hội tụ được trong quá trình
huấn luyện. Được chưa?
Thì ở đây đang nhân tiện đang nói về cái
version này. Tức là cái thứ mà nó dùng
cái kỹ thuật dùng để làm sao chúng ta có
thể chúng ta kiểm tỏa giúp cho mọi người
nó không bị phức tạp quá. Thì đây chúng
ta sẽ nói tiếp về một cái chủ đề nữa
liên quan đến dimensionality reductions.
Dimensionality reduction hay là giảm
chiều dữ liệu. Các bạn chú ý này, ở đây
chúng ta vẫn chúng ta nói về rượu dạng
bảng nhá. Rượu dạng bảng là bao gồm
nhiều hàng, nhiều cột đúng không? Mỗi
một hàng là một sample, mỗi một cột là
một feure. Được chưa? Thế thì
với dữ liệu dạng
bảng ấy đúng không? Có nhiều hàng thì
tốt, có nhiều sle thì tốt, còn có nhiều
cột, có nhiều feature thì làm sao? Có
nhiêu feature để phải xem
về mặt kỹ thuật.
Đúng rồi. Như thế cũng là đơn giản hơn
rồi. So sánh giữa ờ 100x²ình cộng
1000x cộng 500 nó vẫn phức tạp hơn so
với là x² + 2x + 3 đúng không? Trọng số
trọng số nó cái giá trị nó bé đi là được
rồi. Không không nhất không nhất thiết
là giảm độ phức tạp. Đây không phải là
giảm bớt số không nhất thiết là phải
giảm bớt số lượng feature mà cho gì chỉ
giảm giảm bớt cái độ lớn của những cái
feature thôi. Giảm bớt cái độ lớn của
cái hệ số thôi là cũng được rồi. Được
chưa?
Nó đến đâu nhỉ? Nó về giảm các bạn nhìn
nhá. Nó về số cột đúng không? Mỗi một
cột là một feature, mỗi một feature mang
chúng ta là một thông tin đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà nếu mà về số hàng nhìn
chung càng nhiều càng tốt thì về số cột
lại không phải như vậy. Số cột mà nhiều
ấy thì nó sẽ có cái vấn đề như này là
không phải cột cột nào cũng là những
thông tin hữu ích đúng không? Không phải
cột nào cũng là thông tin hữu ích. Ví dụ
mình có một cái bộ dữ liệu về điểm của
học sinh chẳng hạn thì bây giờ mình mình
có một cái cột là màu tóc của học sinh
thì cột này nó cũng chả có ý nghĩa gì
cả. Một tóc mình thấy là nó chả ảnh
hưởng gì đến cái việc là học sinh học
giỏi hay không đúng không? Thế nên ấy là
không phải là cứ nhiều thông tin là tốt
đâu. Thông tin nó phải thông tin nó có ý
nghĩa nó có được chọn lọc đúng không?
Thế đấy là cái thứ nhất. Cái thứ hai nữa
là đấy như vừa vừa
cái thứ hai nữa là gì các bạn? Tưởng
tượng này.
Cái việc mà chúng ta có chúng ta có ôi
tiễn mình sẽ nói cái đoạn đấy nhá. Tiế
mình sẽ nói các bạn tiếp là cái cái
trượt điểm thứ hai gì. Thế mình sẽ nói
này. Thế bây giờ ấy chúng ta biết là
nhiều rượu quá thì không tốt rồi đúng
không? Thì bây giờ chúng ta chúng ta sẽ
phải cách cho giảm bớt số lượng feature
và cái việc giảm bớt này người ta gọi
chung đó là dimensional duty reductions
đúng không? Giảm chiều dữ liệu. Thế thì
các cái k giảm chiếu dữ liệu ấy nó rất
là đa rất là đa dạng nhưng người ta sẽ
nhóm nó vào hai nhóm chính. Một nhóm
người ta gọi là feature selection và một
nhóm người ta gọi là feature extraction.
Các bạn chú ý hai hình này nó hơi ngược
tí. Bên trái thì cái extraction nằm bên
trái nhưng mà bên phải nó lại nằm ở dưới
nhá. Feature selection và exction.
Hôm nọ chúng ta học cái select kb ấy, nó
chính là một cái ví dụ của feature
selection đấy nhá. Thế các bạn chú ý
này, feature selection và feature
exction nó không phải tên của hai ch
toán cụ thể mà nó là tên của hai nhóm
thuật toán. Hai này khác nhau như thế
nào? Thứ nhất, feature selection. Đặc
điểm của feature selection là gì? Đặc
điểm của feature section là nó sẽ
lọc là nó sẽ giữ lại một vài những cái
feature gốc ban đầu và nó sẽ bỏ đi những
cái feature khác. Ví dụ ở đây trong hình
này ban đầu tôi có bảy feature
trong quá trình tôi tính toán gì đấy tôi
biết tôi tính ra được là gì là có ba
feature ít quan trọng sẽ bỏ đi. Tôi chỉ
giữ lại bốn feature thôi. Thì như thế
này gọi là feature selection. Tức là cái
output cuối cùng tôi giữ lại ấy là những
cái feature nằm trong bộ góp ban đầu.
Được chưa?
Cái nhóm thứ hai gọi là feature exction
là nếu mà feature section người ta là
cho đọc đặc trưng thì feature exction
người ta gọi là trích suất đặc trưng.
Trích suất đặc trưng có nghĩa là gì? Chứ
là chưng nghĩa là đầu tiên tôi sẽ
transform cái rượu của tôi đang từ không
gian gốc ban đầu sang một cái chiều
không gian mới.
Cái feure sẽ đều bị biến biến đổi sang
cái dạng mới. Sau đó ở cái chiều không
gian mới này người ta mới bắt đầu người
ta sẽ bỏ bớt đi những cái feature ít
quan trọng và người ta chỉ giữ lại những
cái feature quan trọng nhất trong cái
trường không gian mới này thôi. Thì đây
người ta gọi là feature exction. Cái sự
khác biệt ở đây là gì? Sự c ở đây là
những cái feature cuối cùng mà được giữ
lại trong feature exction ấy, chúng nó
không phải là những fe không phải cái
feature g ban đầu mà chúng nó là cái
feature đã qua quá trình biến đổi, đã
qua quá trình thay đổi rồi. Các bạn nhìn
thấy cái hình này được chưa? Nó là những
cái điểm hình tròn này. Nó không phải là
những điểm hình tam không phải những
điểm hình tho như ở trên. Được chưa? Đấy
là cái sự khác biệt. Feature selection
là đến cuối các cái feature gốc vẫn được
giữ. Tức những cái kích những cái ông
được giữ lại là những vẫn là những ông
gốc còn feure extion là không. Nó đã
được transform ra một chiều không gian
mới rồi. Được chưa? Hai ông này thì mỗi
ông đều có những cái ưu điểm của mình.
Ưu điểm của feature exction là gì?
Thường cái feature mà được giữ lại thông
qua feature action nó sẽ tối ưu hơn tại
vì người ta đã transform nó rồi, biến
đổi nó rồi đúng không? Biến đổi nó sang
cái chiều không gian mới thuận lợi hơn
trong quá trình huấn luyện rồi. Được
chưa? Trong còn trong qu trình hình xử
lý dữ liệu.
Nhưng feature selection đổi ngược lại
thì feature selection lại có có cái ưu
thế về mặt là giải thích.
Đến cuối các bạn có thể giải thích được
là các cái feature các bạn giữ lại cho
feature nó có ý nghĩa gì nhưng feature
thì chịu. Ví dụ các bạn có cái bộ rượu
về giá nhà, các bạn có thông tin về số
tầng này đúng không? Diện tích này, vị
trí này các thứ này đúng không? Các bạn
dùng fe các bạn chỉ giữ lại diện tích về
số tầng thôi các bạn giải thích được nó
ý nghĩa là gì? Nhưng feature các bạn
chịu ta không giải thích được. Được
chưa?
Thế đây là hai nhóm thuật toán.
Thế bây gi đi sâu vào chúng ta sẽ phải
nói tiếp một cái nữa là về cái nhược
điểm của nhiều chiều. Thì các bạn nhìn
này, trong machining ấy người ta có một
cái khái niệm gọi là curse of
dimensionality hay tiếng Việt mình gọi
là lời nguyền của số chiều. Vừa nãy mình
vừa nói với các bạn là gì? Là có nhiều
phí nhiều cột ấy, nhiều thông nhiều
nhiều cột đúng không? Mỗi một cột nó sẽ
là một cái chiều trong không gian ấy
đúng không? Rượu các bạn có 10 cột nó sẽ
là trong không gian 10 chiều. Thì thứ
nhất là nhiều cột ấy thì không phải là
cái cột nào không phải cái fiture nào nó
cũng có ý nghĩa nó cũng useful trong
việc dự đoán là cái thứ nhất đúng không?
Cái thứ hai nữa là gì? Là khi mà số cột
tăng lên ấy chúng ta muốn huấn luyện mô
hình hiệu quả thì số hàng cũng phải tăng
lên nhá. Số cột tăng lên t như tôi nhờ
không tin hơn. Tôi muốn hất lệ hiệu quả
tôi phải cho số hàng cũng tăng lên luôn
thế chứ không phải là cột tăng thêm hàng
giữ nguyên được. Thế nhưng mà các bạn
tưởng tượng này nhá. Ví dụ đầu tiên các
bạn, các bạn thể các ví dụ các bạn có có
một cái đồng xu đi. Các bạn có một cái
đồng x, các bạn thả cái đồng xu này trên
một đoạn đường dài 100 m. Sau đó các bạn
đi tìm nó, các bạn tìm rất là dễ. Các
bạn thể đi dọc cái con đường đấy là các
bạn tìm được. Được chưa? Đây là không
gian một chiều.
Bây giờ vẫn là cái đồng xu đấy nhưng mà
các bạn thả trên cái mảnh đất có kích
thước là 100 m là không gian hai chiều
đúng không? Các bạn thả đồng xu các bạn
tìm sẽ mất thời gian hơn đúng không?
Tiếp trường hợp thứ ba là các bạn bây
giờ các bạn thải đồng xu trong một tòa
nhà cao tầng có 100 tầng. Mỗi tầng có
kích thết là 100 nhân 100 m². Bây giờ
các bạn tìm còn lâu nữa. Tức là gì? Cùng
cái lượng dữ liệu đấy cùng là một đồng
xu nhưng cái khu vực nó được nó có thể
cover được càng ngày nó sẽ càng thưa đi
đúng không? Ví dụ cho ba cái hình này đi
đúng không? Cùng là từng này dữ liệu
đúng không? Cùng là ví dụ cùng là 50
sample đi trong không gian một chiều nó
sẽ cover được khu vực nó
bao phủ nó nó lớn hơn. Trong không gian
hai chiều nó sẽ thưa hơn, trong không
gian ba chiều nó càng thưa nữa.
Nếu số chiều của dữ liệu tức là số cột
ấy tăng theo cấp số cộng thì số lượng
sample hay là số hàng dữ liệu ấy nó phải
tăng theo cấp số nhân nó mới bù được.
Thông thường tỉ lệ sẽ là 110. Tức là gì?
Các bạn có thêm một cột các bạn sẽ phải
có gấp 10 hàng nó mới hiệu quả. Ví dụ
các bạn có một giữa có một cột các bạn
cần phải các bạn phải có 10 sample.
Các bạn có hai cột các bạn sẽ cần phải
có 100 sle. Các bạn có ba cột các bạn sẽ
phải có 1000. Tức là đấy là cái quy tắc
tổng quát đấy. Th chúng ta gì? Số cột mà
ta theo cấp số cộng ấy thì số hàng phải
ta tăng cấp số nhân nó mới bù được. Mà
cái việc số hàng ta cấp số nhân nó không
dễ chút nào. Tại vì sao? Số hàng là số
lượng sample. Muốn có thêm sample đâu có
dễ đâu. Phải đi thu thập phải đi phải đi
đánh nhãn. Mà có phải lúc nào chúng ta
cũng sẵn sàng đâu. Chúng ta có một cái
bộ rượu trên mạng. Bây giờ bảo chúng ta
đi thu hợp thêm. Thua thêm kiểu gì bây
giờ? Chúng ta chả biết nguồn nó ở đâu,
chúng ta chỉ biết là có dữ liệu thôi
đúng không? Làm sao làm sao mà thu thập
được đúng không? Thế thế nên là đấy là
những lý do vì sao người ta phải cách
người ta giảm số chiều của dữ liệu đi
đúng không? Bây giờ tôi không tăng được
hàng, tôi phải buộc tôi phải giảm cột.
Giảm cột làm sao? Tôi chỉ giữ lại những
cột nào quan trọng nhất, có nhiều ý
nghĩa nhất, informative nhất mà thôi.
Đúng không? Thì đấy là lý do vì sao
người ta phải tính cách người ta giảm
chiếu dữ liệu mà đấy là chính là lý do
vì sao sinh ra các cái kỹ thuật feature
selection và feature exction. Được chưa?
Thì chúng ta sẽ nói về cái dễ hơn, cái
dễ hình dung hơn là feature selection.
Feature selection thì rất là dễ hình
dung. V các bạn thấy không? Lúc ban đầu
các bạn có 14 feature, tôi sẽ loại bỏ đi
10 feature thôi. Ít quan trọng tôi giữ
lại có bốn thôi. Thì đây gọi là đây gọi
là feature selection đúng không? Thế ý
tưởng là như vậy. Còn thực hiện nó có
nhiều cách lắm. Có rất nhiều cách. Ví dụ
đi. Ví dụ chúng ta có cách rất là đơn
giản. Chúng ta dựa vào cái gì? Chúng ta
dựa vào cái ma trận hệ số tương quan.
Ví dụ ở đây chúng ta có đây một cái bộ
rượu của mình có cái Tit là cái MPG MP
MPG là my peralon tức là một cái đơn vị
my per galon này tức là cái đơn vị tức
là bao các bạn đi được bao xa đấy dặm
bao nhiêu dặm trên một gal g galon xăng
đấy đúng không một dặm thì bằng à một
dặm thì bằng bao nhiêu ấy nhỉ mình chả
biết đây này 1 mai tức là một dặm thì
bằng à
đây Đây một dạng đậu giờ
đây
đúng không? Đây là cái đ đơn đơn vị nó
nó khác đơn vị chúng ta hay dùng đúng
không? Mai như là bằng một mai là bằng
bao nhiêu?
Bằng bao nhiêu km? Đấy
đây một mai là khoảng mai là khoảng một
một khoảng 1,6 cây đúng không? 1 galon
là bằng khoảng
1 calon là bằng khoảng 3 phẩy à 1 galon
là bằng 3,7 L này. Được chưa? Đấy thì
đấy là cái cột microcalon và chúng ta
muốn sư một cái mô hình tôi dựa vào các
cái đặc trưng như là cylinder placement
không power là mã lực này các thứ để tôi
dự án cái số này. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ tôi sẽ cách đơn giản gì là
tôi tôi sẽ dùng cái ma trận hệ số tương
quan để tôi xem là những ông nào ví dụ
tôi lọc đây tôi sẽ có nhiều cách một là
tôi có thể tôi xem là những giữ lại
những cái ông nào có cái hệ số tương
quan lớn nhất với cả cái target của tôi.
Ví dụ đây bốn ông này có hệ số tương
quan lớn nhất tôi giữ lại còn ba ông ít
hơn tôi bỏ đi. Được chưa? Đây là một
cách. Cách thứ hai tôi sẽ dựa vào cái
hiệp à cái cái cái đa cộng đa cộng
tuyến. Bây gi bây giờ giả thử tôi bỏ qua
cái mcalon đi. Tôi chỉ nhìn ông còn lại
thôi. Bảy ông còn lại tôi xem là những
ông nào đang cộng tuyệt vu. Tôi bỏ bớt
đi. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được chưa? Đây là
cách để các bạn có thể sử dụng coration
coefficient magic để các bạn có thể chọn
đặc trưng. Thế nhưng ấy cách này nó sẽ
chỉ có hiệu quả khi nào cái cách chọn
cái cách chọn lọc đào trưng mà dựa vào
cái ma trận thế hệ số tương quan này ấy
nó sẽ chỉ có hiệu quả khi nào các bạn
không phải lúc nào cũng dùng được tùy mô
hình mới dùng được khi nào thì dùng được
cái cách này
khi nào dùng được
khi nào dùng được các
Không phải ý đặc cộng tuyến bản thân nói
dùng ừ dạng số là 1 đúng dạng số là 1
còn gì nữa chỉ dùng được khi mà
khi mà tôi chủ định tôi dùng mô hình
tuyến tính mô hình tuyến tính thì các
bạn dùng cái này được chứ còn các bạn
dùng mô hình phi tuyến dùng này chả có ý
nghĩa gì cả mô hình phi tuyến bạn dùng
random fred thì không dùng cái này được
không cái đấy tất nhiên là tất nhiên là
về mặt bản chất chúng ta sẽ chọn những
ông nào có cái tương có cái liên quan
mạnh rồi thì đúng rồi nhưng mà ý là nếu
mà chúng ta dùng mô hình phi tuyến ví dụ
như là random fred thì dùng này chẳng có
ý nghĩa gì cả tại vì là mô hình phi
tuyến nó không khai thác m hệ tuyến tính
run fr nó không quan nó không quan tâm
đến cái mô quan hệ linear này thì các
bạn dùng nó chả có ý nghĩa gì cả được
chưa
đúng không thấy nếu ví dụ những mình
tuyến tính của mình đơn giản các bạn
dùng nhận hệ số tương quan là xong đúng
không thế tiếp này
một cái cách nữa là người ta sẽ dùng cái
ngưỡng của cái varian cái phương sai tức
là tôi xem là ông nào mà có cái phương
sai mà bé hơn một cái ngưỡng đấy tôi sẽ
bỏ đi. Được chưa? Ông nào có cái phương
sai nhỏ hơn một cái ngưỡng tôi bỏ đi. Vì
sao tôi lại bỏ đi những cái picture mà
có cái phương sai nó bé quá thì phần sau
mình sẽ giải thích nhá.
Đây là buổi ngày mai mới kịp nhá. Hiện
tại
phương sai
khi mà mô hình được chọn feature ấy thì
mô hình nó sẽ luôn các bạn nhớ là cái
hôm chúng ta học về tiền xỉ dữ liệu ấy
đúng không? Các bạn nhớ là cái hôm học
họp về tiền sữ rượu ấy mình có nói với
các bạn là gì? Là các cái mô hình trong
machining ấy nếu các bạn không tiền xử
lý ấ thì nó sẽ có cái xu hướng nó sẽ tập
trung vào những cái feature có cái giải
giá trị nó lớn đúng không? Cái phương
dày nó lớn ấy đúng không? Thì đấy đấy là
lý do vì sao mà khi các bạn cho nó đặt
đặc trưng ấy nếu các bạn chỉ muốn giữ
lại top k đặc trưng thôi thì nó sẽ lại
bỏ bớt những ông mà có cái variền nó cái
phương sai nó nó bé đi đúng không? Tại
vì là mô hình bản chất nó là nó tập
trung vào những ông có độ phân tán nó
lớn đúng không?
Độ phân tán bé nó có cái bất lợi gì thì
ngày mai mình sẽ thấy cho các bạn nhá.
Mai chúng ta sẽ nói về cáiề liên quan
đến variance được chưa? Ở đây thì tại
chúng ta cứ tạm thời chúng ta hiểu là
gì? Là mô hình nó sẽ quan tâm đến những
mô hình cái feature nào mà có cái value
nó càng bé thì mô hình nó sẽ càng ít
nhìn vào đấy. Được chưa?
Còn nữa là gì? Chúng ta dùng đây feature
selection rất là dễ được chưa? Feure
dùng chúng ta dùng lo. Dùng l này các
bạn nhớ vừa chúng ta vừa vừa mới slide
này xong đúng không? So sánh giữa
giữa feature selection với cả fe đúng
không? Đây là chúng ta dùng lể để chúng
ta loại bỏ đi cái feature nào nó ít quan
trọng đúng không? Đấy lo này
hoặc là nếu chúng ta dùng random for có
rất nhiều thuật toán mà chúng ta sẽ đánh
giá được cái khái niệm gọi là feature
importance được chưa? Trong nó bao gồm
cả random forest. Với random forest
chúng ta sẽ đánh giá được cái feature
importance tức là gì? Cái tầm quan trọng
của từng feature. Các bạn cho mình hỏi
này, theo các bạn với R forest những cái
feature như thế nào thì nó là feature
quan trọng?
Feature như thế nào thì nó có thiếu quan
trọng.
Theo các bạn trong fred feature như thế
nào gọi là quan trọng?
có độ phân biệt lớn á.
Ừ.
Nhưng mình có phơ
có thể nó lớn hơn này, nhỏ hơn kia.
Có cách nào đơn giản hơn không?
Ừ. Ừ. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Ừ. một nói
chưng ông nào đóng góp nhiều kiểu kiểu
như vậy đấy. Feature important đúng rồi.
Ông nào đóng góp nhiều đúng rồi đấy.
Hiểu cái này cũng đúng.
Nhìn vào một cái random fest theo các
bạn là feature như thế nào là là feature
là feature quan trọng
là ch nó làm sao
là feature mà nó tham gia vào nhiều cây
trong cái Rom Fred và nó nằm ở gần gốc
đúng không? Nó tham gia vào càng nhiều
cây nó nằm càng gần gốc thì nó càng quan
trọng đúng không? Thì đây người ta cũng
đánh giá dựng cái trên cái điều đấy đúng
chưa? Feature important thì ông nào ông
nào quan trọng thì tôi sẽ sắp xếp thứ tự
của nó đúng không? Ông nào mà ít quan
trọng tôi bỏ đi. Được chưa? Ngoài ra đ
có một vài so toán nữa chúng ta cũng
đánh đánh cũng đánh giá được cái cái
điều này. Thì thật ra các bạn dùng thư
viện các bạn cũng không cần phải đi quá
sâu vào. Các bạn có những cái thuật toán
nó sẽ có cái phần feature important này
thì các bạn thuật toán nào có các bạn có
thể các bạn dựa vào đấy để các bạn đánh
giá xem là ông nào quan trọng ông nào
không đúng không?
Rồi. Ok. Có bác nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Bác nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Ok. Thế hôm nay chúng ta xong cái phần
feature selection rồi.
Mai chúng ta có phần fish. Ừ cái này
chắc là để mai đi. Cái này nó nó hơi
nhiều còn có mấy phút mai nhá. Mai chúng
ta nói về nốt feature các bạn nhá. Được
chưa?
Ờ chúng ta có này chúng ta sẽ còn một
cái project nữa về recommendation system
nhá.
Khóa này chúng ta đi nhanh hơn nh lớp
này chúng ta đi nhanh hơn những cái lớp
trước nên là có thể cuối cuối khóa chúng
ta còn dư ra một hai buổi mà mình sẽ nói
về một vài cái chủ đề về de ming với về
nhá.
Ok.
Ok. Mai vẫn giờ này các bạn nhá. Mai vẫn
giờ này nhá.
Ok, cảm ơn mọi người nha. Chúc mọi người
ăn tối ngon miệng nhá. Mai vẫn 6 gi nhá.
Bye mọi người nha. M.